good morning everyone and can I welcome
you to the meeting of development
control committee at mid-suffolk
District Council I'm just going to run
through first of all some domestic
Arrangements uh can I just ask please
that you make sure that microphones are
turned off when you're not speaking and
can I ask please if you are speaking or
wish to speak but do not interrupt other
speakers will hold separate
conversations while there is a speaker
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
I just ask everyone to just double check
your mobile phones are on silent or
Switched Off and if you have a laptop
open could I ask you to turn the volume
down so we don't have um pings the time
emails come in
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern dot gov app so
could I ask members just to make sure
you are logged in and ready to use the
app please
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live on
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewings the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded by
entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
if you do hear the fire alarm today can
you please leave the building
immediately by the fire exit to make
your way to the assembly point at
Ipswich Town Football Club
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at the end of each floor
please do not enter the atrium the
ground floor area and walkways and if
you are in the atrium when the alarm
sounds please follow the science to the
nearest far exit sign nearest fire exit
do not use the stairs or lifts please do
not re-enter the building too which is
two we're told it is safe to do so
okay so the main
planning meeting
for Miss Suffolk District Council so my
name is Matthew Hicks I'm one of the
councilors with my colleagues here on my
left who'll make a decision on the
applications before us today at
mid-suffolk District Council the local
member may speak on an application but
may not vote on the application which is
why John sitting over there John Phil's
sitting over there and he will have an
opportunity to speak but not vote
uh in the room we have the chief
planning officer Philip Isbell the area
planning manager Gemma Walker the legal
advisor Ian de Perez case officer Braun
Kurt uh Braun Curtis will be coming to
the meeting via teams to present the
application we will later on have the
health environment officer and we have
governance officers Clearfield part
Alyssa Norman and Patrick Richardson
Todd in the room as well and councilor
Byrne as the ward member for the second
application will be joining us for that
item
so I'm now going to move on to the
agenda uh
apologies for absence and substitutions
please
no mercy chair lovely thanks very much
to receive any decorations of disposable
pecuniary interests and other
registerable non non-registerable
interest by members do we have any to
declare
none received thank you
Declarations of lobbying I've been
lobbied on the first application is that
and the second okay so that's across the
board thank you
any decorations of personal site visits
by members none thank you the minutes of
the meeting held on the 18th of January
we just got one change to them uh Claire
hand over to you yes thank you chairs so
um section 75.1 has been corrected to
include uh councilor Manson's name and
that's been updated in the paper printed
copy thanks
okay is there anything else apart from
that one change that anyone wishes to
raise no so can I have a proposal for
the accuracy of the minutes Council
mayor and the second deck councilor
Passmore thank you uh governance officer
will now conduct an electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote should
now be showing in progress
thank you chair so as you've confirmed
rope four that's
five votes for and three abstentions
thank you thanks very much okay
um move on to the next item which is to
receive to receive notification of
petitions and calls from the council's
petition scheme are there any nobody
straight onto the treasures of planning
applications we've got two before today
we'll stay in the same order as they are
in the agenda so the first item I would
like to bring in the case officer
uh good morning uh so it's the land to
the south of church from summersham and
the land to the east of Channel verstal
and and over to the case officer
morning chair councilors thank you very
much okay so this first application is
for a solar farm with battery storage
development you'll see on this first
slide that there's two application
numbers and that's because the site
itself crosses the administrative
boundary between mid-suffolk and baber
district councils and I'll show you that
in more detail as we go through the
slides next slide please
so the site area is this sort of
y-shaped area of agricultural land
comprising of three Parcels of land with
an access from Churchill burstal and the
um zigzaggy orange line on the right
there is a underground cable route
connecting the development to the
National Grid substation at Bunnin Lane
which you can just see on the right hand
side the picture there next slide please
this is their very basic slide showing
the application site outlined in red
next slide please
and a bit more detail of constraints
here you can see that the entire site is
within a locally designated special
landscape area so both the mid-suffolk
local plan policy cl2 and for the baby
local plan their policy cro4
you can see that the Woodland Lane
Bridal way passes across the southern
portion of the site where the axis is
traveling from east to west
there's also a footpath right-of-way
which leaves that Bridal way along the
eastern boundary of the site traveling
north and then turning slightly West and
joining the channel on the Northern side
of the site it passes between
Fields five and six which I'll show you
the the numbering in in a moment and
then alongside the edge of field four
before falling back to the channel
you can also see the flood zones
associated with float and Brook which he
joins the site on the western side along
with the channel highway so the channel
forms part of the western and Northern
boundary of the site though the road
actually occurs around so I'll try and
tell you when you're seeing images
whether you're looking from the channel
on the western side or the northern side
next slide please
this slide shows you the administrative
administrative boundary between babe and
mid-suffolk so you can see that the area
um that falls within mid-suffolk is
um Field 4 which is on the Northern side
of the site
it accounts for approximately 25 to the
site and you can see that also parts of
the cable wrote the undergrounded cable
route going to mid-suffolk as well
the coloring within the site also shows
you the agricultural land classification
of the land so the blue area is grade
two
the dark green area is grade 3A and the
light green area is grade 3B
so for the purposes of running policy
the mppf and your local plan policy cl11
the grade 2 and grade 3A are best and
most versatile agricultural land
So within the parcel of land excluding
the cable route Corridor the passive
land that will see the development in
mid-suffolk so about 25 of the overall
site that area is approximately 7.7
hectares
and of that all of the land as you can
see is best and most versatile and the
proportions are approximately 33 grade 2
67 3A
so just so you have that detail on BMV
next slide please
this slide shows you a bit more detail
of the local designation of the SLA so
you can see the green is the designation
for policy cro for in the baber local
plan you have policy CO2 which
designates
um slas across our district but there is
a section in the topic paper for that
policy which recognizes the value of the
landscape around the area of floton and
so you have this little extra Pocket of
SLA which extends the the
designation for labor effectively it's
it's recognizing that it sits within the
same landscape so you're not you're not
seeing any visual difference obviously
between the districts
next slide please
I've included this slide for you so that
you can see both the evolution of this
application and you can also see some of
the other proposals that are considered
as part of the cumulative impact
assessment of this application this
application has been screened as eia
development on the basis of the
potential for cumulative effects with
other developments within the locality
the application when it first came in
was the extent of the red line site that
you're considering this morning that
y-shaped land to the center bottom of
this slide but it also included the land
shown outlined in dashed purple
at the top of the slide
so it included access close to the
community center at
um summersham and some areas around
floating as well so those Parcels of
land have now been excluded from the
scheme following some of the
consultation exercises and the feedback
from Community and Technical consulties
so what you're now looking at is just
the y-shaped parcel towards the bottom
of this slide
also shown on this image you can see the
red cross-hatched areas of land that is
the extent of an application site for
the Gray Barn solar farm that is an
application currently under
consideration pending determination
and then further to the east along
Thailand you can see the hatched red
site
that it is the extent of land subject to
an application by EDF energy for a solar
farm again currently pending
determination
slightly further down the slide you can
see black cross hatched boxes they
depict the bigger bigger one depicts the
National Grid substation at Bullen Lane
and also accessed from Bullen Lane you
have the extent of the East Anglia one
substation complex and the East Anglia 3
converter station complex just next to
that
and then just outlined in blue just for
purposes of identifying it on this slide
there's a small rectangular parcel of
land which is the UNESCO battery storage
site so that's a development that's
almost complete for a standalone battery
storage facility and that is accessed
through the same route from Churchill
burstal as this development
next slide please
so this slide shows the numbering of the
fields just so that you can see which is
which so Field Four is the area of land
which is generally in the mid-suffolk
area and is one on the Northern side
which has um is proposed to have solar
panels
across the majority of that area Field
Five is the larger area in the center
which again has much of the solar
and then field six on the northeast side
has some of the Solar Development but
also has the complex for battery storage
and substation Etc
and the cable root leaves the site at
that point you can also see on this
Slide the root of the
footpath right away which is shown in
dashed yellow
which leaves the bridal way at the South
passes along the eastern boundary of the
site
passes between Fields five and six and
then along the edge of field four to the
channel on the Northern side of the site
in pink dashed on a similar alignment to
that is a permissive route for path so
that is a more obvious desire line route
that Walkers are using and is a
permissive rather than a statutory route
but it takes more more or less the same
path
there is also a permissive Bridal way
route which leaves that footpath and
passes between Fields four and five
between before joining the channel on
the western side
next slide please
so this plan just shows you that layout
in a bit more detail together with the
buffer of land on the southern side from
the right way and it's got some of the
landscape planting details shown on
there next slide please
this is an extract from the layout plan
just to show you a bit more detail of
the arrangement for field six showing
the battery storage and substation
complex and other other pieces of
electrical equipment
uh next slide please
this slide has got a bit more detail of
the landscape
proposals for screening and you can see
um buffers around each of the field
sections
next slide please
Innovation drawing just showing what a
string of solar panels looks like and
you've got the height
overall height in three meters and the
height from the ground at the lowest
point 0.8 of a meter
it's worth noting that another change in
the activation since it's originally
submitted is that the panels are now to
be fixed rather than tracking so they
won't move and that has implications for
reducing the potential for noise impact
as well as the potential for glint and
glare impacts next slide please
just to give you an idea of what
substation building will look like next
slide please
and control room next slide please
and the batteries are to be stored in
containers shipping containers style
buildings so these buildings are sorry
these containers are about 12 meters
long
and um
about three meters high two point Sorry
2.4 meter side
next slide please
so moving through to the photographs
this is the access from Churchill you
can just see in the center of that
picture a sign on the side of the axis
which has the UNESCO logo and all of the
directions for the construction traffic
for that development so it's using the
same access as that development so that
access exists already from Churchill
the next photographs I'm going to be
taking you around the site as if we're
now traveling Westward so we're going
towards the channel so the next slide
please
is an image taken from the channel
Highway looking into a field access
and it's really the main point of visual
access to the site from the channel the
rest of the site is either very well
screened by mature vegetation or it's
set behind existing properties which are
further further to the south of the
channel but you can see here the
Topography of the site so you can see
how it rises slightly above the level of
the channel Highway and you can also
just in the foreground see the brickwork
for the Culvert of floating Brook which
passes alongside the same sort of route
as the channel Highway actually crosses
the highway in some points
depending on the height of the river
next slide please
now traveling around still on the
channel but at the north side of the
site so you can just see in the
foreground the finger post for the right
of way so so what you're looking at um
in the center of this behind that tree
line is Field Four the right of way
passes along
the outside of that tree line
um and then South to join the rest of
the network next slide please
this has taken more or less at the same
point but looking further east so you
can see the finger Post in the bottom
foreground there
and this temporary field access so the
field that you're looking at in the
foreground is not part of the
application site it's actually part of
the Gray Barn application site but
behind that parcel you would just be
able to in in the sort of mid background
you'd be able to see parts of field six
next slide please
so it's part of the right of way as it
travels through the site next slide
please
pass to the right way as it passes
between Fields five and six
next slide please
and this is an image from the permissive
route which travels between Fields four
and five next slide please
um and this view is taken from the right
of way which passes across the southern
part of the site where the axis root is
looking northwards towards the site next
slide please
and again along that right of way
um but in a slightly different position
just looking that way you get a sense of
some of the characteristics of the
landscape here
with lots of mature planting trees and
hedges the agricultural land and also
you've got the backdrop of some of the
wirescape of the pylons and wires going
into this into the substation
next slide please
all of these next views are taken from
the submitted landscape and visual
impact assessment so they are not of the
site they are of the landscape setting
of the site so they're giving you the
wider view so this is this image is
taken from a right-of-way
within birthstone just um just a little
way south of where the site is looking
towards the site next slide please
and this is a right-of-way which is on
the southwest side of birstall so
looking the other way towards the
channel and the site
on the right of this image next slide
please
it's a little further along that right
of way looking towards the site so
you're getting a sense here of the
Rolling Valley Landscape which is a
characteristic of the of the landscape
character assessment for this area and
part of the reason for the designation
as an SLA
next slide please
so views towards a site from floating
road again you're just seeing some of
the characteristics of the landscape
with uh in dispersed Woodland and it's
dominated obviously by agricultural land
with some some built development next
slide please
so views again towards the site from
floating Road
next slide please
and towards the site from a right of way
between summersham and floating
so quite quite open and flat in this
area but you can see changes in the in
the Topography of the landscape through
these slides next slide please
this is just showing the Viewpoint
locations of those photographs so the
black arrows are showing the pictures of
the site itself
and the circles the pink and yellow
circles are showing you the wider
Viewpoint location so showing you the
landscape setting
please
so I've just included a bit of
information here about the benefits of
the development in terms of
renewable energy generation so the
development would generate the
equivalent
um energy usage of approximately 7450
homes each year and a saving of
approximately 6250 tons of carbon each
year
next slide please
okay that's the end of the slides for
the moment
um if we could go back to
slide
sorry
let's have slide
can we start with slide five please
so I'm going to start with um
best and most versatile agricultural
land as I said when I was talking to you
about this slide you do have policy cl11
which recognizes the importance of
agricultural land and seeks to protect
um most versatile agricultural land so
best and most versatile being grades one
two and three a so the mid-sufficient
portion of this site is best of most
versatile grades two and three but
you'll also see in the assessment in the
report that's before you
the consideration that's been given to
the fact that the application seeks a
temporary permission
that the development of the solar panels
are on
um file driven rather than foundation so
slightly less intrusive for the for the
soil that the um that the development is
on and that the development is
reversible and that we have a condition
in your recommendation for
a reinstatement scheme to be agreed
together with ensuring we retain any
enhancements in terms of landscape and
biodiversity Improvement
um if I then take you to
slide seven please
so again we're looking at the cumulative
impacts of the development you can see
how I've set out the details of the
relevant policies in the local plan and
the various weight that we're
attributing to those policies depending
on how they are called with the mppf and
the objectives they're in
again we're not querying the principle
of the development we're dealing with
the mppf objective that renewable energy
development should be granted if the
m-peps are or can be made acceptable
recognizing that the mid-suffolk local
plan and core strategy have specific
policies which recognize the difficulty
that uh
can be faced by this type of development
in being accommodated in the landscape
of mid-suffolk
um particularly large-scale developments
but what's interesting to note here
given the reduction in the size of the
skiing and the relative enclosure of the
site
um
given all of the Landscaping that exists
together with the mitigation that's
proposed landscape officer has concluded
that the the impact is fairly localized
to the site as obviously the views from
the rights of way which which go across
the site but then the impact diminishes
fairly quickly as you get beyond the
site because of the level of screening
it has arising from the topography and
the screening
so you'll see that we've concluded that
whilst there is some tension between the
objectives of the plan
um and the proposal the the benefits of
The Proposal as a renewable energy
scheme are considered to outweigh the
impacts in terms of impact on best and
most versatile land because of the
temporary impact and reversible impact
um and the again for similar reasons the
landscape and visual impact
um
I've got I've got through sections on
various other topic specific issues
dealing with
things like the historic environment
impact on the setting of of listed
buildings
um archeology Etc
we've also got cumulative effects
assessment in each section of of that
which hopefully makes sense as you've
had a look through it also dealt with
um
issues of ecology and the calculation of
biodiversity net gain so which is Way
Beyond the emerging requirement of 10
we've got a quite significant net gain
to be delivered as a result of the
development and
the highway safety and rights of way
issues we've got a section there we have
had concerns from birstall Parish
Council about the um the traffic
particularly the construction traffic
and the routing
um but we have had advice from County
who are satisfied
subject conditions to deal with
construction management plan Etc
and then we've also got
a section dealing with immunity impacts
including noise
um glint and glare
and Public Safety particularly
um concerns have been raised regarding
the battery the safety of the battery
installation there has been a lot of um
a lot of press coverage about incidents
relating to battery storage and we've
worked closely with officers that
Suffolk Fire and Rescue
to ensure we have the information that
we need to for for members to make a
decision and you'll see in the
recommendation there is details of
Emergency Response plan to be secured
so I'll leave it there for the moment
thank you
thank you very much
um so can I just double check then so
just just
so in our papers on page 32
um we talk about uh paragraph 174 of the
mppf policy fc1 CS5 CO2 and you
mentioned I think cs11
so what you're saying is
within those policies there are concerns
but the overall View
is that the benefit outweighs those
items
yeah none of the policies out
a you must not develop on best and most
versatile agricultural land
um but the mppf requests 174 requires us
to have regard to the
um natural Capital benefits of the
countryside so as part of recognizing
the value of the countryside and valued
Landscapes
um it's also including in their economic
and other benefits that are derived from
the countryside including best of most
versatile land so it's just recognizing
the value of that rather than saying
it's an ABS it's an absolute one way or
the other and your policy cl11
encourages conservation of agricultural
land it does afford particular
protection to BMV
but again that doesn't it is not an
absolute one way or the other saying
that you we mustn't it doesn't it
doesn't say we would refuse development
on BNB so I'm weighing the impact on
best and most versatile
um and
uh you might hear later from
the applicant on the the or the um the
landowner on the benefits that might be
derived from the development in terms of
the ongoing operation of this parcel as
agricultural land and adjoining parcel
yeah and that is the officer opinion
that these policies and that's really
what we are therefore being asked to
consider today whether those policies
the weight of those policies that should
be given to the application
yeah yeah
okay so happy to and yes we'll start
down the end Council
um thank you chair um thank you Ron very
much for that um I've got um two
questions
um could we please just get a view on
the fact that
um baber
um District Council heard this
application last week I think Anna voted
on it and just to the context of that m
in relation to the decision that we have
to make today just to give a bit of
further information on or Clarity really
on that um and and the actual specifics
that we are voting on as in the whole
application as opposed to just the bit
that's in mid-suffic kind of view I
asked that exact point of my briefing um
we are a separate Authority with a
separate responsibilities making
separate decisions on land within
mid-suffolk but I don't know Ian if you
want to add anything you obviously well
understand the points I don't I think I
may not need to say anything in bronze
you want to go first if and I'll
sure okay thank you yes so baby District
Council did consider this application
because as I said at the beginning it's
a duplicate application made to both
authorities for the same development but
made in duplicate because this site
happens to cross the administrative
boundary both authorities are
considering the same development but
obviously in context with the respective
development plans which are slightly
different for the two authorities the
decision of baby District Council last
week that was resolved Grant and
development
as the as per the officer's
recommendation which is the same report
and recommendation that you have before
you accepting insofar as there is
reference to specific development plan
policies and that decision has no
bearing on members
um ability to make one or other of a
decision or a different decision today
[Laughter]
occasion regardless of whether bits are
in mid-suffic or baber or whatever
thanks and secondly um just with regards
to the landscape
um
the special landscape could you just
sort of enlarge a bit on that particular
paragraphs sort of
7.67.7 in terms of
um similar to the the best and most
versatile land issues of argument as it
were are we
um the balance of the special landscape
and also the landscape mitigation
um for that area thank you very much
thank you yes so you'll see in the
report that I'm speaking a little bit
about
um whether the site and its setting is
considered to be a valued landscape in
the policy sense so just to give that a
bit of context
um again
um 174 of the mppf talk so but there is
no longer a blanket
um preservation of the countryside for
its own sake since the revision of the
mppf Matt's moved towards more
recognizing
um the the value in landscape and that
is not how a Community Values it or how
users of that landscape value it's in a
purely policy sense so testing of fat of
that policy has resulted in conclusions
that valued Landscapes are those that
have specific and demonstrable physical
characteristics that elevate that area
above other areas of normal Countryside
for one of a better word so when looking
at this area it's not just because
there's a local designation that doesn't
necessarily automatically make a
landscape valued in the mppf sense but
it's about looking at the various
characteristics and and how what they do
what those physical characteristics do
in terms of elevating something to
um something that's more than just
Countryside that might be in the rest of
the district so
I have concluded that this area could be
considered a valued landscape but that
there's not
um because of the containment of the
site that you can see from the
photographs because of the existing
level of mature lands a planting and
because of the
um proposed mitigation as well
and also you'll see in section seven
that your landscape officer has had
consideration for the potential for in
combination effects so that is the
experience of users through the
countryside of this development here but
also any other developments in
combination that would then have a
cumulative effect on that experience and
and he has advised that there is is no
potential for in sequence effects and
that because the visual impacts there
will be a visual impact but that will be
fairly Limited in its in its reach
because of the topography and the and
the landscape setting Etc that that
um
is to be weighed against the positives
of The Proposal
and hopefully I've concluded that in
that section
councilor Manson
thank you I've got a few questions if
that's all right but can I first go back
to the
split um boundary thing because I think
I'm now more confused
um I thought councilor Hicks said we
were assessing a planning application on
land that is in mid-suffolk and then I
had councilor eberne saying we're
determining the whole application and
the whole application isn't in
mid-suffolk land so I'm now more
confused than I was before
okay sorry if someone can comment on
that before I ask my questions
so the whole proposal is before you
which is comprised on the whole
application site but the development
plan May that you you're working with
the mid-suffic development plan may only
apply to certain elements of the
development
whereas the impacts of The Proposal just
because they lie on one side or the
other administrative boundary won't
necessarily not impact the communities
of the district so it's relevant to have
regard to the whole
development but only in so far as your
policies provide for the consideration
well if I got that right Ian I couldn't
put it better myself I mean it just for
context one there's an alternative way
of these matters being dealt with this
for one Council usually to delegate to
the other the whole
that has been done as
to delegate the decision but it's it's
not being done in this case
um and it's not always appropriate to do
it often and particularly where there's
a matter like real renewable energy
where there
of
concerned by committee
so so
unfortunately Jim when I usually speak
it adds confusion rather than Clarity so
I'm a little wary of this but
um I can see Council has already put her
head in her hand so apologies for that
um
the point here is that you have to apply
your development plan policies to the
applications
part of the site that you have in your
area
but nonetheless you are looking at the
totality of the application that
the round but you're only making a
decision over the part that lies within
mid
policies that you have
suffer
okay I'm not sure I'm any the wiser but
um so if if we were to come to a
different decision than baber
on this application what would happen
so you have as part of your sorry chair
is that okay for me to answer that is it
I thought it was a question to me sorry
no come in thank you so as part of your
recommendation you have
um a request for members to comment on
instruction to the chief planning
officer to respond to an appeal so we do
have notification of an intention to
appeal that was against the
non-determination of the application
um obviously there will hopefully be a
determination today but that potential
for that appeal would still exist if
um the committee decided to refuse the
application which you're entitled to do
um for reasons that you see fit but we
would need to also ask for your
resolution on defending the appeal as
appropriate
a couple of other questions
um uh we're asked to look at the
cumulative effects of all of those other
applications which are still in process
um now how do we
how do we assess
them in terms of you know uh if this one
gets granted that clearly has an effect
on the next one because of the
cumulative effect so is it a case of the
first come first served gets might get a
preferential treatment because the other
ones aren't there yet I'm not quite sure
how that how we can actually assess the
cumulative effects fairly uh so I'd like
a bit of clarity on that and my other
question is about the temporary nature
of the planning permission
um is there some sort of decommissioning
plan
um is there a and I've just looked to
see if there was a construction
management plan but there's something
called A ctmp and A C EMP in your list
of conditions and I can't find them on
your list of abbreviations at the front
of the report are they construction
management plans and is there a
decommissioning management plan thank
you
okay sorry I'll start with that first
then apologies for all the acronyms I
was hoping to catch it all in the
glossary but obviously didn't ctmp
construction transport management plan C
EMP construction Environmental
Management plan so they are they are
similar things but they deal with with
the specifics of transport and working
hours Etc and then specifically to do
with biodiversity so we've separated
them out
um as advised by technical technical
consulties
um the decommissioning so
um
the recommendation
I've called it a reinstatement scheme
so the third bullet point in your
recommendation temporary planning
permission removal reinstatement and
retention of biodiversity enhancements
the wording that I have drafted for that
condition
asks for a strategy for reinstatement so
explanation of how the development will
be the physical elements in the
development will be removed and the site
will be reinstated but not reinstated to
as it exists now because we're looking
for any biodiversity and Landscape
enhancement measures to be retained
as far as possible
so we're left with a
you know a better position than we're in
now
um
can I just could I just come back on
that so does that also include a
decommissioning transport management
plan because presumably they'll need a
load of trucks to get the stuff off the
site just as they had a load of trucks
to get it on the site
the so the transport assessment that's
part of the application has been
considered by county and that includes
the decommissioning phase
the condition that we we can certainly
include that that's specifically that
that scheme includes consideration of
how the the logistics of the
decommissioning
um shall I answer the question about
cumulative effects
[Music]
thank you so the like I said at the
beginning the applications have been
screened as eia developed on the basis
of potential for cumulative effects
there was a judgment a few years ago
called Vanguard which talked about
um what developments should be included
in the scope of cumulative effects
depending on what state stage they were
at in determination so it is appropriate
for the developments that are not yet
determined but are in the system and are
reasonably foreseeable which is the
wording of the Judgment I believe
um to be considered those both of those
other applications are eia developments
as well for the same reason both of them
include environmental statements all
three environmental statements have been
reviewed externally by the same
and the same people
um and found to be sound in each case
and we have enough information
um in all of the submissions to make a
judgment on the cumulative effects one
to the other the point Council Manziel
you asked about
precedent I don't think you use the word
but I think you were you were talking
about the precedent of the decision for
the others it as in all things planning
it's each case on its merits and it is
each one uh you know first come first
served to a degree
um and on the basis of the development
plan that's enforced at the time so the
granting of this scheme if members were
might so minded would not necessarily
have an impact on the others
um to be granted but it would firm up
the um presence of the development in
the in the consideration of cumulative
effects although they're required to
have regard to this scheme anyway
um
thank you for the glossary it was a
tremendous Hill
uh cool um going back to SLA can you
give us a feel for how much land was in
mid-suffolk is designated special um
oh goodness well is it is it a
um a designation that we we slept on 90
of the land or is it a special area that
we select for special consideration it's
mostly the river valleys across
mid-suffolk
um we we used to have a really nice
image that was a piece of paper that
folded out of the insert pocket in the
local plan doctor which showed you the
whole District I would probably Hazard a
guess at about 10 Phil might be able to
tell me if that's over egging it but
just bring Philip in on that point
yes Jim then when there is a map of
these things but it's actually less than
you might think I mean they are special
landscape areas because they are not
blanket coverage over cost and as bronze
says they are mostly districts
um it's on the website we could probably
find it and
worked at it thank you I've got a feel
for how special they are thank you thank
you and and what you're looking at here
the term in the nppf slas have been
around for many years
they have
um kind of evolved into the concept of
valued Landscapes I suppose well there
is the concept these days of valued
Landscapes which are not slas per se and
you have to look at the particular
characteristics but from our advice to
you they give you a clear indicator that
there is a landscape here which is
worthy of consideration and it's for you
then to make the decision as to whether
you agree they are valued if they are
valued whether that has any consequence
on your decision
um
my next question is a bit um technical
really
um units one of the um lobbying
documents I received pointed out that
the units used to describe the battery
storage area are in their words rubbish
I do remember my school days a long time
ago get the units wrong and the homework
appeared with a red line through it
because it was meaningless
how
on how important is it for the reports
you've received to be accurate because
it seems that they're possibly not
okay so this arises
um from a projector who's concerned that
the battery storage element of The
Proposal would need has the substance's
consent as well as planning permission
and it's that's something that we've
been working on for a little while and
is evolving as we go because battery
storage development is a fairly new
um across the country
the need or otherwise for hazardous
substance and consent doesn't affect the
ability of the committee to make a
decision on the planning permission
it is something that officers are
following up with the applicant
separately
um the information and we're following
up also with the health and safety
executive the information that we have
at the moment is that the
um the substances and the potential for
substances and that's where the
um the capacity of the battery
installation was a query because there
is some evidence to suggest that the
capacity of the battery has uh um a
consequential impact on the risk of loss
of control incidents which is where
there is there may be the potential for
the release of hazardous substances
you can see that in my report I've I've
spoken about
um hazardous substances in the other
matters section just to in brief but
what I'm saying in essence is that the
reasonable foreseeableness which again
is the wording in the regulations of
hazardous substances occurring is
is
a little far removed from there so I'm
concluding it has the substance is
concerned it's not required although
I'm still holding that sort of under
consideration with our legal team and
other colleagues as we go along it is
separate from the planning application
it looks like it's possible that that
the battery storage will be controlled
by the health and safety executive
anyway under classification
um labeling
um and packaging of substances
regulations so we may not need to
duplicate that which is a principle of
planning that you don't duplicate other
other
um regimes but um so that's that's the
principle of the objection which has
featured in the majority of other solar
proposals with battery storage that are
that are coming forward at nsip so
things like the Sonica proposal the long
field proposal so I'm working with those
colleagues to bottom out the Hazardous
substances side of things in terms of
the fire safety and Public Safety of The
Proposal
um as I said we've been through the
application with Suffolk fire and rescue
who are satisfied with the amount of
information they have relating to the
technology to be installed and the way
the development needs to be operated the
subject to a condition which you've got
in your recommendation
to secure an emergency response
strategy
I'm just checking I have included that
because I can't see it now sorry I might
need to add that to your recommendation
um is that okay
yeah thank you
Castle fast and we were next thanks
Matthew just two or three quick points
please
um
I think this this might be relevant the
conditions here that did the baber
decision had any conditions to the
planning consent which might be relevant
and just following on from that um Roman
um on page 21
um not surprisingly the comments to the
designer crime officer would it be
possible to condition the enhanced site
security if it were to go ahead which
talks about
um
well for example ampr automatic
automatic ignition at the site entrance
would it be possible to condition that
if the committee decided to grant
approval
thank you um baby District uh committee
didn't add any conditions they weren't
the recommendation as it stands um and
yet committee can can add or amend the
recommendation as they see fit thanks
and the other point I wanted over the
page on page 22 where it talks about a
106 agreement
um what sort of what are we talking
about here potentially
because I've not assessed an application
like this before what sorts of things
might be included in a 106 agreement so
I think I think are you talking about
the comment from the County Council no
no sorry from the development
contributions office yeah so the County
Council developer contributions officer
has suggested that we look at securing
Community benefits from The Proposal
um unfortunately there's not not
currently a lawful mechanism by which to
do that uh bilaterally so it would have
to be something offered unilaterally by
the developer there isn't there isn't
anything being offered in this case
there was a judgment called the
resilient energy judgment a couple of
years ago we do you may be familiar with
the fact that we have a 106 on the eye
wind turbines and we get a community
benefit in the form of financial payment
out of those which goes to community for
education and other purposes but that
was before this judgment the Judgment
now says that's not actually lawful we
can't use 106 to secure a financial
contribution to the community we do have
a series of other benefits that are
coming out of this scheme such as
um the permissive Bridal way of footpath
and information board scheme but um we
don't have a financial contribution that
we're securing and there is no mechanism
for us to do that
so this would just have to be by
agreement then but there is no you can't
effectively do any apart from
negotiation we can't we can't demand it
and it's not a material consideration
for the determination of the application
if if one were to be offered
and therefore or the fact that it's not
offered is awesome it's a good will
offer nothing more so he can't condition
it which is what it says in the paper no
no yeah the County officer did did ask
us to do that
um but but I had a conversation with
them and I asked them to to tell us how
they thought that we might be able to
secure that I haven't had a reply from
them and I think that's because the
conversation went over resilient energy
and we realized that there isn't a
mechanism currently for that it is
something that's being looked at there
is a current consultation out for end
zip level development and Community
benefits and it's very possible if that
consultation
um delivers anything that it will
trickle down to Town and Country
planning act type developments as well
so we're keeping an eye on our keep
members updated in general
thanks a lot cheers thank you Council
Mattson
thank you chair yeah if I could return
to
um where councilor Manson was going
earlier
um that that was helpful but
um this paragraph 7.16 and and
particularly slide seven
um
the I wonder if we could have another
look at that to
um preferably enlarged to to actually
see which Things Are
insect you which are approved and which
are might happen because we haven't
determined them yet can we sort that out
on that slide
so you found it let's see thank you yes
slide seven so the developments that
exist
if Alyssa just shows the pointer to the
black hat
boxes so the large one at the bottom is
the National Grid substation at Berlin
Lane and there's a series of pylons that
go in and out of that the two boxes just
to the north of that East Anglia one
substation which is completed and
operational East Anglia 3 converter
station is under construction currently
and then just to the left of that
outlined in blue the little rectangle
the UNESCO battery storage site is
almost complete
everything else that you can see
outlined in red on here is either the
application site that you're currently
considering all the other two solar
sites which are currently pending
determination
the other the other question I received
what you've um called reinstatement I
think at the moment ago
um
in in in the event that um we've reached
the end of the 40 years and
um
the value of the land into the future
um is is not very great for whatever
reason
um
are we have we any security or Bond or
whatever to ensure that reinstatement
can take place
um even if the company which then owned
the site has gone bust in layman's terms
so I'm recommending a condition to deal
with that and you'll know that the
Planning Commission runs with the land
so the enforcement of that would rest
with us but the responsibility to comply
with the condition with would lie with
the landowner
we have got a bond for decommissioning
on other projects in the district that I
wind turbines so that is something
that's possible but um but we're
recommending that a condition would be a
reasonable way of achieving the same
thing
okay any other questions for clarity
before we move on no okay well thank you
oh sorry John yeah
sorry I was uh just wanted to make sure
perhaps about the battery far Hazard
issue
um we sort of it seems a bit like a sort
of a grenfield tower process you rather
hope someone else will look after the
problems I just wanted to be assured
that you have looked at the papers by Dr
Fordham and press that Professor
Melville and that you have looked
carefully at the Aloha Allianz Global
report on battery safety
police officer
yeah the latter obviously is the largest
insurer in Europe so probably has some
reason to have a level of concern so
every reason can we not express opinions
at this point it's just for questions of
clarity Ron have you had a look at those
reports we'll have a look at those
um those those
parties are
people who have made representations on
a number of other nzip solar cases and
Battery which I continue to follow with
other colleagues across the country and
um Suffolk fire and rescue colleagues
are working with other authority
colleagues across the country to work up
best practice for dealing with battery
storage development so
um I'm satisfied that we have all the
information and we have all the advice
from the relevant technical quantities
yes sorry briefly I've just just found
my my other note about this the
um I fear officers are going to confirm
we haven't got any kind of um
sequential testing available anywhere
with which
um I mean it may be that
the other sites that are on the on the
slide there under consideration
um are far more suitable than this site
um but I fear we haven't got any any
sequential testing policy that will let
us think about that
um so it's the same story with most
planning applications the question
before you is whether this site and this
development is acceptable not whether an
alternative is these developments reia
so there is a requirement for some
consideration of Alternatives but not
necessarily there's no requirement in
the regulations for those alternatives
to be pursued just an assessment of what
alternatives exist
including do nothing that sort of thing
so that but the question before members
is is this application as presented
acceptable
okay so we're going to move on to this
to public speakers
um so first of all we're going to move
on to the parish council now um the site
encompasses three parish councils
brownford floton and summersham so we've
we think it would be appropriate that
all three get three minutes each due to
um it's impacting the three so whichever
order you want to go if you want to just
go on my list it says Caroline Walton is
going to go first so are you happy with
that and we have a timer here for three
minutes uh we will ask you to keep to
the three minutes please
when you're ready thank you
thank you Mr chairman Brantford Parish
Council accepts the need for and
supports renewable energy however not at
any cost and disregard to the community
hosting it Brantford is already making a
huge contribution to the nation's energy
Supply with up to 30 of the country's
low carbon and renewable energy planned
for distribution through Brantford
substation we are overwhelmed by the
number of energy projects in Brantford
the cumulative effect of this
development and the impact of other
adjacent solar Farms proposed is
unacceptable to the village and its
surrounding communities it will have a
devastating effect and a huge cost to
the environment
Brantford is being consumed by
development and now threatened by solar
industrialization dominating the
surrounding landscapes
proposal conflicts with the local
development plan national and local
policies and guidance increasing energy
supplies from Renewables does not
override all other considerations
similar proposals and appeals have been
recently refused by mid-suffolk for
reasons for reasons of harm to landscape
and Heritage assets and inappropriate
use of best and most versatile land too
many exceptions are being made this must
be refused here today
the environmental environmental impact
and loss of agricultural land used
caused by this application appears
disproportionate to the small amount of
energy being produced by this project
the loss of 35 hectares of Greenfield
arable agricultural land in the gipping
valley special landscape area to power
only
7450 homes
application undermines government intent
to protect such land National policy
states this should be avoided for
development and lower quality land used
instead yet none has been considered
a huge amount of residential and
industrial buildings granted in recent
years have a cumulative impact on
Brantford and its infrastructure
and this encroachment is of great
concern and being ignored
however all of these applications
granted are without any solar or
renewable systems in place and now we
are considering covering our productive
Fields with them this is madness
I trust you have all read the council a
briefing note sent to you Brampton
Parish Council supports this document
and has crucial information and concerns
that must be considered here today
particularly the Hazardous substances
consent manufactures specifications that
seem to be missing traffic movements
security and fence provision Heritage
assets landscape and flooding
we ask you to refuse this application
here today for these reasons thank you
thank you very much what I plan to do is
have each Parish Council speak then take
questions to all the parish councils
because they may overlap with some areas
so next we have thank you for that you
still have plenty of time so you just
need to let the egg timer run through
and next up is Nicholas Carter from
floating
Sam
totally opposed to this application the
parishioners have floating are totally
opposed this application for several
reasons
for one being treasury used to this land
from being Prime agricultural Landing to
becoming a grotesque industrial area or
blot on our beautiful landscape
the applicants claim their proposed use
of land is temporary
Times Square we're taught most 40 years
to most people Mr chairman 40 Years of
nowhere temporary but it sounds good
even more serious than the destruction
of a pleasant Royal environment it's a
potential loss of food production
we've calculated that should this
application be approved it would entail
the loss of more than 10 000 tons of
food
are you really of a mind to deny the
world ten thousand tons of food
already in this country we have to
import more food than we can produce
I'm surprised you as a counselor
considering this in such depth it
appears to be in total variation of your
own policy document C11
I'm also surprised the landowner having
said he's a friend of mine should be so
Keen for his land to be sacrificed
he normally promotes com conservation
for example by leaving a wide field
margins to encourage wildlife and the
parish is grateful to him for that
of course there's a lot of money
involved here
I had solar panels fitted to do over my
house 10 years ago and very pleased with
them and with the amount of the
electricity they produced by all means
encourage solar panels but in the
correct place and Prime agricultural
land is manifesting not the correct
place there aren't 10 positions they
could indeed should be fitted the Amazon
building on the side of the Old Sugar
Boot factory
the warehouses are blakenham Gateway 14
Snow Market there's 156 Acres there
twice the area we're talking about here
but this is Limitless but it should not
be a question of food or energy we need
both and you as a council need to be
strong enough
to restrict the erection of solar panels
and rooftops so agricultural land is
still available for food production
counselors of choice is yours are you
going to vote for Midsummer to retain
its productive farmland
or are you going to vote for it to be
blighted by potentially dangerous
eyesores
should you choose the latter we and
future Generations will never forgive
you
I hope you all sleep well tonight thank
thank you very much uh James Rook from
summersham you're next
uh we're not using the egg time because
it takes too long to run through because
you're short in the three minutes so
we're using a timer here restaurant
um good morning everybody
um I'm James Rook farmer
a farmer's son
and I'm here to share my parishes views
as Vice chairman of the somerset Parish
Council
our community are huge supporters of a
Greener future and believes solar has an
important part to play
however solar is not perfect and it
leaves its own carbon footprint with
manufacturing and decommissioning in
particular
our community is strongly against this
proposal
and does not believe that East Anglia as
a net exporter of energy should be
putting solar panels on such valuable
resources as some of the best Farmland
in the UK and in fact the world
the greenest thing we can do is grow our
own food on our doorsteps
and let's use more suitable places such
as Brownfield sites and warehouses and
homes for solar panels
whilst our community understands a
farmer's motivation to receive a
thousand pounds an acre guaranteed for
40 years
rather than working very hard in the
hope of 150 pounds an acre
we feel this may be a wise choice for
the individual but not for the Greater
Community
our community is very keen on protecting
our environment and the Beautiful
Suffolk Countryside for their families
their children grandchildren and the
next Generations
the community unanimously rejects these
proposals
we feel this is not a green vote
that would be beyond naive
sorry I lost my place um in East Anglia
we create more energy than we use we
export energy to other areas of
Brownfield sites and we lose energy on
route
we should be generating more energy at
point of use
please on behalf of our community don't
be fooled into sacrificing some of the
best agricultural land in the country
technology that will be Antiquated
incredibly quickly
this is a green Trojan Horse and you
have to allow this today you'll be
opening the door unnecessary
unnecessarily for far greater loss of
much valued Countryside in the future we
have the likes of Tesla tiles coming and
much much more we don't need to ruin our
Countryside our community wants a truly
green future and we have a lot of
challenges ahead but getting rid of
productive Farmland would simply be
Reckless we don't believe we have to
choose between food and energy
there are far more sensible Energy
Solutions in more sensible locations
however
if we did have to choose we would prefer
that our great grandchildren
eat by candlelight
rather than starve with the lights on
thank you
thank you very much
okay happy to take questions
if there any questions for the parish
councils at all
yep that's a mess
yes I I you know obviously sympathize
with lots of things that the parachutes
have said please
opinions please
it's no we're not in debate no one
question about that is is and this is
this is a particularly any of the
um
speakers who have come from the farming
background and the food argument
um have you have you have made any
assessment of the the food that can be
produced
um
with and underneath
solar panels we understand sheep and we
understand chickens are feasible
um say co-co co-production methods
do you want to ask the applicant that
question after they've spoken
okay
yeah yeah I think for the last speaker
who has the farming experience if you
want to comment
um first of all I'm unaware of this
working anywhere else effectively with
livestock
uh it's you
you play have these
uh
you can't put that infrastructure in and
look after livestock
I'll see you you might be able to have
one sheep and take it for a walk this is
not going to be productive
thank you very much
no other questions okay so thank you for
that we'll now move on to an objector
Samantha Main and again you have three
minutes when you're ready
thank you what can I say after two and a
half years of this I have walked the
foot paths that's around this site and
look across it for many years I enjoy
walking across the fields and I enjoy
watching the fields change and the crops
grow as the Seasons move on
I know many people are quickly
forgetting how beneficial
being in the countryside can be to
well-being and we all learned that
during the pandemic but the residents
here haven't forgotten it this is a
special landscape and it is a valued
area as the officer even recognizes and
it's not just because it says so in the
local plan we all know it
I wonder my few remaining minutes to
highlight some misjudgments that were
made in the baber meeting given these
flaws amongst others judicial review is
a very real possibility you might hear
from the landowner about the
environmental work that he does the
wildfield the wide field margins he has
and as a parish we are very grateful for
that we like looking at those it's a
shame then that the plans for this
proposal would destroy some of those
margins by covering them in internal
roadways solar panels cover them in
fences and digging them up for cables
a lot of taxpayer grant money went into
some of those environmental managers
labor councilors asked about the
temporary nature of the proposal a
condition is proposed to limit it to 40
years but I think you're smart enough to
know what can happen to a condition that
a developer doesn't like
we can only hope the council has a good
enforcement team
and it's also entirely possible that in
39 years time the owner of the site
could submit an application to extend
the life of the solar farm for another
40 or however many permanent years he
likes
another misjudgment was around the
relevance of hazardous substances to the
application we've had that quite a bit
today hazardous substances are relevant
to Public Safety and Public Safety is a
material consideration even the
committee report admits that in the
event of a battery fire there would be
air and water pollution
we already have three battery storage
units in the area
the report fails to highlight that
groundwater in this site is within a
protection zone for an aquifer that
supplies Ipswich in the surrounding
areas with its drinking water it'd be a
shame to see some of those hazardous
substances get into that
and lastly the issue around precedent
isn't a coincidence that court cases
refer to previous court cases
developments must indeed be decided on
their own merits but previous decisions
including appeals are material
considerations in that decision
that means if you approve this contrary
to the development plan and let's be
clear this is contrary to the
development plan then other developers
can use that as evidence against you a
few months ago mid-suffolk refused
another solar farm application in
Wrecking Hall and it's being appealed if
you approve this application today as an
exception to the development plan then
that can be used against you in that
appeal
and not just for that application for
all applications in the future too
president your time is up so it will
have to be the last sentence please
precedent is very real so saying no to
this application isn't saying no to
solar it's saying yes to the local
development plan
thank you very much do we have any
questions at all
no okay thank you very much for that
we'll now move on to a supporter John
cousins again you have three minutes
thank you very much my name is John
cousins I'm the owner of Brook Farm with
my son Robin and my daughter Emilia I
have always farmed in the most
environmentally friendly way that I can
manage since I took over the management
of the farm in 1985 I have undertaken
considerable activity and it has been
mentioned and I appreciate that to help
Wildlife by removing over 75 Acres of
arable land from Crop Production to
create areas of Woodland new Hedges
Wildflower Meadows and annually planted
areas to provide nectar for
invertebrates and food for Birds this
equates to 22 percent of my farm
solar area will equate to a further 24
percent which means half my farm will
have been taken out of arable production
it's been very difficult to consider
this whole project it's not an easy one
and I don't believe that some people
believe that they have environmental
motives but I do
I see the areas involved as potential
habitat there's going to be no
destruction of field margins there's
going to be no change there's going to
be enhancement of field margins and
larger areas for the environment
my view is that the
farmed area an arable crop is hostile to
Wildlife 40 years yes a very short
period of time but in the last 40 years
we've seen over 40 percent of our
biodiversity to 50 percent of our
biodiversity disappear in the last 20
years the number of insects have halved
the talk about food security good stuff
but
there is only 57 Acres of solar panels
in this country at the moment that's one
acre per thousand acres
meanwhile there are two hundred and
fifty thousand acres of crops arable
crops grown for biofuels fuels to put in
cars which we won't be needing in 30
years because
maybe they'll all be Electric
we export two million tons of wheat
there's a perception that we don't
export anything we export two million
tons of Wheat and at the moment there
are one million tons of wheat in store
waiting to be exported on the World
Market and it's looking quite difficult
to export it
so we we have got food security
and my small area isn't going to
jeopardize that it will be grazed with
sheep look at the evidence in Australia
and the Sheep production has actually
improved in Australia under solar panels
much improved
um performance by sheep and it will be
grazed it'll also be planted with pollen
and nectar species and Wildflower
species which I believe will be hugely
beneficial
Zone time is up to the last sentences
that will probably do because I've gone
completely off my script and and and
thank you for listening
thank you very much and
Monsieur thank you
um two questions really
um one is it more viable to for you as a
farmer to diversify another solar farm
and take the rent from that than it is
from agriculture the second question is
how many sheep have you got
at the moment we have about 40 years
with followers on on the farm it's it's
a fairly low intensity grazing unit I do
that in in partnership with an ex
pigment who lives on the farm still and
I would look into him to do grazing on
this area or I will introduce a grazia
um so so you know that that is something
I really want to do in terms of
profitability
this is my farm is a small farm it's
325 Acres that is small it's inefficient
in terms of of scale
obviously I that the financial rewards
of this are a consideration but equally
my passion and I have worked all my life
in in Wildlife both professionally and
voluntarily
my passion is the environment and and
I'd like to think that I can achieve
things on this farm that will show just
what can be delivered through a
sympathetic scheme delivered in a
sympathetic way
thanks so much okay we move on thank you
very much next up we have the applicant
Simon Chamberlain and again three
minutes please
good morning I'm Simon Chamberlain I'm
from Enzo energy we are the applicant
here we have significantly reduced this
scheme in scale and size as a result of
feedback from communities and both
statutory consultees this has resulted
in a development which no statutory
consultees have objected and your
officer has been able to recommend for
approval
no land will be lost to the development
it's temporary and after delivering the
benefits it's entirely reversible so
accordingly we respectfully ask you to
approve this proposal
thanks very much any questions at all
yes Castle Mansell
um I just wanted to ask about the um
the fact that you've changed this
application from having rotating panels
that follow the sun to static ones and
I'd just like you to if you could
explain how that affects the efficiency
of solar panels
it doesn't so much affect the efficiency
of the solar panels because it Still
Remains the Same panel whether it's
fixed or whether it's tracking
um what it does though is it slightly
reduces the yield of the sodium farm so
if you can imagine yeah
yes they are the yield is not as great
from fixed panels as it is from tracker
panels however owing to reducing the
land take and moving it just or keeping
it just on those Southern Fields the
actual sort of curvature there's
slightly rolling Fields there they don't
lend themselves as well to the layout of
tracking panels
okay any other questions nope okay so
thank you very much we now move out to
the ward member uh Council John Field
over to you
thank you
I'm close enough to that
I've really heard such a set of
competent responses from parishes and
objectives
uh it's good to hear that perhaps
difficult to follow
um some really logical arguments
I also have to say one respects John
cousins integrity and and his views
although I believe it's mistaken that
you need solar panels to achieve the
environmental benefits he can achieve
I think the problems with climate change
make it imperative that we change many
aspects of life
as we currently lead it one of the most
important is migrate from fossil fuel
for power generation to energy sources
that releases your own carbon
and I think oh well virtually all
residents except that point
we all expect change
however
the same residents believe as you've
heard that it's foolish
to to sacrifice agricultural land from a
large area of high-grade Farmland the
best and most versatile grade two and
three I
think the farm produce can of course be
substituted by Imports shipped in at
considerable damage to the environment
however that does not bring
certainty of supply
as you've heard they believe that there
is an alternative approach
which is basically putting these solar
panels on other buildings on on those
that are available in the various
Warehouse areas that we we now have and
certainly on domestic housing
there's about 29 million house roofs in
this country that could have could
Supply power to us
and I think
estimates of up to 18 gigawatts of power
from from the roofs of warehouses so
there are alternative solutions to this
problem
I think that's what the mppf actually
asked us to look at when we consider
development in the countryside
and if I can just run through a set of
bullets
so it's trapped around the back so it's
difficult
um
I was going to come through a set of
really bullet points to my mind
summarize what's been said
the first is that the amenity of the
surrounding Villages and the
attractiveness of the vital walking
routes will be severely compromised
with a negative effect on physical and
mental health and consequent costs to
Health and Social care
I think that while habitats of some
species of wildlife will be enhanced
boundary fencing will improve roots and
compromise overall of other species
the development will have a significant
adverse effect on local food production
and will be replaced by Imports using
carbon intensive transport
this development particularly taking
cumulatively with the others proposed
would dominate The Village of floating
and have a major impact on burst or
Bradford summersham and little blakenham
these Villages have already accommodated
major wine farm related infrastructure
obviously the great National Grid
substation and various other power
related equipment
any argument that there amenity has
already been compromised
so it's appropriate for it to be
destroyed I believe is forced
it's reasonable to severely if it's
reasonable to severely restrict the area
consumed by onshore wind power
generation then surely it's reasonable
to restrict solar power installations
to be ancillary to other necessary
infrastructure
only on various roofs and maybe even
above car parks
to move on a little the technology
include employed by the large batteries
provided to provide very short-term
compensation for the intermittent nature
of solar PV generation prevents a
significant risk of fire with toxic
chemical release
and we've heard that's been properly
assessed I wonder if that's after the
two fars at sackers in the last month
which I believe are caused by lithium
batteries
the intermittency and daily cycling
nature of photovoltaic power generation
are poorly matched to the need
and therefore make it a best a minor
contribution to the urgent need to
replace current generation with low
carbon alternatives
I believe last year solar power provided
less than four percent of the UK hispan
needs when if you look at wind power
it's supplied about 39 percent
some of you is really to say please
reject this application encourage
installation on domestic income
commercial property
and that is
my case
gosh do we have any questions for the
ward member
no okay I've been asked um I think by
someone if we just take a quick break so
what I propose is take a 10 minute break
before we get into the debate can I just
remind members please not to discuss the
application that is before us at the
moment
um please during the break and we'll
start again at five past eleven by the
clock on my left which is different to
the one on my right
okay welcome back everyone so before we
go into debate uh Mr Isabel just wants
to come back on a couple of points
thank you chairman uh yes uh councilor
mayor asked about special landscape
areas by the power of the internet we
have an answer to the question which I
think we should be able to show you now
accepting that that's a very large scale
plan if you look at the cursor at the
bottom of that slide and if you can just
move that area you can see
so the special later is on that plan are
green vertically hatched so that gives
you the extent of slas across the
district and in particular because we're
not interested in the others this is
valid landscape is not defined by the
fact you've got a designation of it it
is it is other than that that's the area
of slas across the district generally
and that's the SLA in particular here
so just wanted to put that up because I
did have to find it and I thought it was
useful to cancel
the standing
so thank you for that Alicia the
other point I wanted to pick up on was
more generally in your table papers you
have a comment from Mr Ballard making
reference to some legal aspects
um we have had council's advice on the
reporters it stands so I think from our
point of view we are comfortable with
this
uh
I think I would wish to correct a couple
of points that Mr ballant has made to
you that
um he has said on the uh the fifth page
of the table papers that the first Duty
in deciding an application is to
establish whether or not the proposal
according to the plan read as a whole
including not not only the state of
policies but all their objectives and
the supporting text and you will know
that there is a difference between
development plan and material
considerations
the development plan
policies and the maps and the supporting
text and the objectives are material
considerations so they are not quite the
same thing
yes you need to have regard to the
relevant policies in the plan and you
need to be seeking to achieve the
purpose of the plan but you do need to
be considering the fact that they are
not one simple thing and they are not as
a whole strictly speaking entirely the
development plan
so it's also a point of correction I
wanted to raise
um the as far as renewable energy is
concerned you have a policy I think
paragraph 5.7 of the report refers to
CS3 which is your core strategy policy
um and in that we say that policy is not
up to date in terms of the nppf so
um I think we would have to take issue
with the statement from uh the
correspondent that there is no evidence
the plan is out of date
um the plan as a whole you have to take
each and individ each individual player
policy and consider on the application
whether the relevant parts of that are
up to date if we are looking at the
question of up-to-dateness under the
nppf
that is what is relevant to your
decision and from our point of view CS3
provides a policy context that was set
at its time
and is no longer up to date
today similarly the reference that Mr
Ballard has made in relation to core
strategy objectives again and we take
back to the point that they are material
considerations
but they are not the planning policies
that
subject of section 386 which we all know
and love in this
um
committee so there is some caution I
would say to the way that you are
addressed on legal matters in that
um I'll leave it to any discussion and
anything Mr probably wishes to add
further to that but from our perspective
We believe We presented you with a uh
reasonable and fair
these things and there is a choice to be
made and that is what planning
committees do across the country thank
you Jim okay thank you very much so
members we've had all the information
put before us we've heard um from
various speakers we've had a
presentation of the case officer and
obviously we've got the papers in front
of us it's now time for us to discuss
debate and to come to a conclusion
if you're ready to speak please just put
your hand up yeah cancer possible and
cancer even
um thank you very much Matthew well
this is a very complicated and a
difficult decision I find to to
um come to a conclusion because there
are many balancing factors here
um
and with my knowledge of farming I can
understand why
um there is support for diversification
energy production Etc but
I think the issue of food security has
been brought into very sharp Focus since
that terrible invasion of Ukraine maybe
this is something that's been
progressing for some time
I'm also concerned
that the work that the district council
is doing regarding tourism the visitor
economy and so on and I do sit on that
group doing that and the impact on
landscapes um
detrimental and I know we're only
looking at a small part of the overall
scheme which adds to the complexity from
my personal point of view
but I do have to say that looking after
our landscape and agricultural
production the overall scheme including
in both districts I think could probably
produce in a good year maybe 300 tons of
wheat I'm not saying it's in wheat
production all the time forever and a
day
um obviously depending on where the
conditions it does make a difference
but I think overall food security is an
important issue yes we have a thriving
agricultural export industry in this
country and imports but then again if
you do look at the carbon input
um impact or having to import things
like that I do think there is a
significant issue
um I haven't completely made up my mind
on this but I do think preservation of
the landscape are not entirely convinced
about the need to put up solar farms and
I know this is a relatively small one I
absolutely accept that so at the moment
I am moving towards um a
this application but I'll we'll wait and
hear what other people have got to say
as well thank you thank you Council
event
and thank you very much chair
um as as my colleague said it is a very
complex
um application and I think I welcome all
the um people that have contributed
their views um with their experts or or
local experts as it were so um that's
very welcome and
it's also good to see that there has
been
um negotiation or liaison between the
developer and the the community
um to some extent
I think um overall
you know I think we'd all like to see
solar panels on warehouses
um and on areas of Brownfield land you
know in the mid Suffolk we we own a
massive um Business Park that personally
I'd like to see covered with
um solar panels but that's not what
we're discussing here you know this
isn't a warehouse this is a um
area in the in the
um
areas of land
um I think
one one of the issues that that we have
here at Mid Suffolk is that we don't
have a policy for Community value of
land and that's something that
personally I'd really like to see you
know we've got a small part a special
landscape area but we we don't have
anything that we as plan in the planning
committee can actually rely on in terms
of of what is the the community value of
a particular area and I think that would
be very helpful if we had and similarly
we don't have any policies on on on food
on food um production and again that
would be very useful to have
and I think the overall we kind of you
know in the planning committee we aren't
experts we are
expectors so we rely on Expert views and
we listen carefully to the views of the
of the local people and to the applicant
and so on and so forth and
with this application it is complex it
is in a lovely area of
um
Suffolk and at the moment I think you
can tell from me I'm sitting on the
fence as to where I go from here but I
just wanted to put across those those
points here and I'll look forward to
hearing from my fellow counselors thank
you thanks very much
thank you yeah difficult
um for me this
boils down to
really three issues visual landscape
impact
BMV and the storage
we've heard that the visual
impact will be limited due to
containment mitigation
and yet it sits within an SLA
hence to my mind should be given greater
protection
it's only going to be temporary
I struggle with the world temporary I
worked for 40 years and it didn't feel
very temporary when I was going to work
um
so
there are going to be I think quite
significant ecological benefits
you know a large field of wheat or a
monoculture is a biodiversity Wasteland
so
having
what intents and purposes will be
increased grassland will be significant
Improvement
so what's the struggle with visual
impacts I I could be persuaded that the
impact is limited
battery storage
I think sometimes
we're asked to make decisions that we're
not
technically
really equipped to make there are
obviously issues with battery storage
but we here do not have the the
knowledge all the understanding but
we're required to make a decision
it is worrying
that the applicant
didn't get the units right it might only
be a small thing but it just raised the
question in my mind do they fully
grasp and understand the issues around
battery storage
but the end of the day
our technical advice is
that it's okay so again I could be
persuaded there on the battery storage
best most valuable land that that's
probably for me it's a Crux of the
matter
there are ecological benefits
we have as a council declared a climate
change emergency
so
should we
a stagger cultural land to generate
electricity to help deal with that
climate change emergency
temporary it's to my mind it's not
temporary in terms of time but I could
be persuaded it's temporary in terms of
it's only using piles to hold the panels
so it can be reversed relatively easily
but on balance I think I'm beginning to
feel that we're not making best use of
the land if we approve this so I'm
tending towards refusal but again like
the rest of my colleagues I'd like to
hear what they have to say thank you
councilor Humphries who are next
thank you Mr chair
um pretty much a similar vein in some
respects I am a fan of innovation I'm a
fan of renewable energy without shell of
adult someone mentioned earlier that
perhaps in the future all cars will be
driven by electricity and therefore
there's a reason for this well actually
there's just as much work done on
hydrogen engines at the moment and
Toyota have just released their first so
maybe it'd be hydrogen in the future the
fact is no one really knows but it's a
point well made
um I'm also a fan really of
self-reliance self-reliance as a nation
on energy provision for our people for
now and in the future and also food
Reliance and food security there are two
different things actually when it comes
to security and your ability to be
independent as a food supplier but they
blend there's lots of government stuff
on that however is really important
um I'm also keen on protecting our
landscape we just mentioned this is an
SLA so that's definitely an important
factor for me this is our green and
pleasant land we should protect it but I
understand the push for solar because
this is sunny Suffolk so there's an
argument for both cases
um the war in Ukraine really has proven
a lot of things to us about Reliance
about our own capabilities about our
domestic capabilities on energy and on
food and both really important and it's
not just about suppliers about prices as
well if we can produce them all the
prices should be less no that's not an
exact science
we talk about driving towards net zero
and I get that and I commend the
applicant actually for all the work he's
done previously in trying to prevent
protect the environment well done and we
share more Farmers with that same
attitude but that doesn't mean we should
just go do you know what
because of what you've done you can do
this I'm not so sure but thank you for
what you have done when we Thrive
towards net zero we're talking about as
a nation not just as a district but
let's talk about Suffolk itself and we
look at our Net Zero Drive we've got
nuclear power stations we've got another
one about to be built that nuclear power
station size we'll see will provide
Power for six million households think
about that it's incredible and it'll
reduce the carbon offset by nine million
tons a year
that's pretty good isn't it Pacific
that's a good drive towards net zero not
just one small solar farm but real big
stuff and then we look at our Coastline
and off our Coastline we've got some of
the biggest wind farms in the world I
think we're doing our bet and I think
we're doing our bit really well when it
comes to solar I also see the advantage
of that but I don't think it should be
in our Fields I'm a fan that this should
be on all the warehouses that we're
building on Gateway 14 all the ones that
we're putting on the Enterprise gateways
all the hangers that are here from
dishes second world war airfields you
name it the reflective places where you
can put solar panels that actually do
not affect the countryside because
there's already something Industrial in
place and I think that's quite important
I'd like to look at the argument side of
it and I'd like to take to page 31 is
that a few issues with this I'm sorry if
I'm rambling between notes but I wrote
so much because thank you for your
contributions it really set my mind a
race because you all had some really
important points if we go to page 31
this is the argument really 6.8 overall
therefore the impact on BMV is not
considered to be such as to Warrant
refusal of this application this is
because any inherent tension with policy
cl-11 is mitigated by the factors
referred to above and I'll take to those
factors
so and I'll summarize a couple of them
rather than read the whole thing out it
talks about there are a number of factor
specific to this application considering
the asset and the assessment of impact
on BMV land first is part of the es the
applicant is among other things describe
the steps that were taken to assess
alternative options and I think that's
really important he did do some work on
that and he argued very well as to why
they couldn't take place and that's fine
if we now move down to the other bit
steps have been made to minimize the
impact of the development of BMV
including the proposed panels to be
installed on ground driven piling
similar to fence posts
rather than with concrete foundations
the provision of low intervention
grassland between the panels which suit
was sheep grazing and biodiversity we
spoke about Wildflower planting we
talked about the biodiversity it's all
very important but we're going to plant
wild flowers and they're going to put
sheep on there how long do you think the
wildflowers are going to last it's the
counter argument actually and as we've
discussed before there's loads of things
on the internet to create the internet
where you can actually argue against
that being a positive
but that's just
similarly's opinion I guess
it's also important to note the
application six permission for a limited
period of four years I've looked around
this room there are very few people here
will be alive in 40 years time that's
how long it is okay it's not temporary
it's temporary in the fact that it's a
Prof it's a defined uh defined length of
time temporary as in the true
description of the word but it's not
really temporary and really that's a
really good point like you I spent a lot
of time in work and it certainly wasn't
temporary so this is not a temporary
solution
so let's just get away from all that
gloss and that Smoky Murray shell and
see what it is it's 40 Years of loss of
BMV and if we look at that BMV value in
case people haven't I have it talks
about
um let me have a look just get the I'm
sorry for rambling on but uh I think
it's important if we look at find a
thing the guide to assess and
development proposals in agricultural
land this has been pushed out by the
government in Natural England and it's
to help councils decide on things like
this and it talks about the MPP apps
it's not just some woolly sort of soft
Lefty sort of idea this is based on fat
and by documentation but if we scroll
all the way down it's really important
it talks about how to assess
agricultural land it talks about the
grades and again not everyone will know
this but grade two it's quite a
proportion of this land isn't it from
what I've seen from all the pictures
that have been put up today in the
discussion and it talks about this land
with minor limitations that affect crop
yield which means it's very good and and
actually the other definition of grade
two is very good okay so it's not poor
agricultural land once it's lost it's
lost for 40 years right it's incredible
um so it talks about that grade three
good to moderate quality agricultural
land and 3A good quality agricultural
land capable of consistently producing
moderate to high yields of narrow range
of variable crops especially cereals
well guess what the Ukraine war taught
us we have a Reliance on cereal crops
hello so therefore sugar beet and
everything else cereals grass all the
stuff we need rapeseed and 3B moderate
quality agricultural land so none of
this and I have heard the word poor none
of this land is poor land
unless you'd like to argue otherwise
cool
so I have a real issue with it the 40
years the effects on the visual scene
the fact that we're losing valuable
agricultural land to me that's a
nonsense we should not be pushing this
through and I am sided on this I am not
going to vote in favor of this
so that's me thank you
very much
Council Matson
thank you chair
yeah just the first to say to the
objectors goodness me this committee and
other committees and other places we
have tried and tried to put more solar
onto roofs of houses and roofs of
warehouses but we don't have the
um
policy context from government that
would allow us to insist on that so
that's that's a problem which we wrestle
with continuously I particularly struck
by the fact that this is um largely in
special landscape area I'm a big
defender of those as a big big area in
in the world that I represent
which I
um
bring forth fairly regularly at um
planning applications
um
it is it is a Pity that this is so um so
much of this sort of three quarters of
this I think we decided was the best and
most versatile agricultural land that is
a problem
however
we have declared a climate emergency and
although it is true that the the
electricity needs to be produced
nearer to where it is consumed
I millions of roofs in London for
instance it is also the case that the
forecast of the future for electricity
demand is is two or three times what
we're
um what we're using at the moment which
does require a very great deal more
production
even even in East Anglia
um so that's those are the things that
are pushing me in the one way but then I
look at or both ways with it and then I
look at the the problem
we need to we need some solar Farms
but are the better sites and we haven't
really got the
tools and the evidence to help us to
judge that which which is is pretty
frustrating
um this is certainly not the worst site
um but it may not be the best site so I
I find it very difficult and on I'll
hear what others still are going to say
uh just a point of party from yeah just
to point Clarity for me
um cousin Matheson mentioned this is uh
for local it's going to be provided for
the local communities or local areas can
I just as Point Clarity confirm that any
electricity generation will it be size
well or from a solar panel once it goes
into National Grid
thank you so it's not strictly for local
yeah
well unless it's in batteries so can I
have a confirmation of what we've got
thank you I'm not sure that's relevant
to the application before us
uh councilman
yeah just a point of fact really several
people have mentioned a warehouse roofs
Gateway 14. um there are issues with
putting solar panels on all the
warehouses in Gateway 14 because the
National Grid cannot accept the
electricity so it is not just the
council failing to get them on ruse
there are infrastructure problems and
that actually
supports this scheme because the
substations are close enough to accept
the electricity
thank you I
for mayor because I was going to mention
the fact that that does seem to be the
the issue here is that these fields that
we're talking about now
happened just happened to be adjacent to
a substation and I think that is the
prime reason for someone applying to put
a solar farm here and yes I I understand
that that is an issue
um with putting solar panels on roofs of
buildings elsewhere in the district
um and and maybe we um as a nation and
not just as a council need to address
that issue
um because it clearly is a problem that
these fields that happen to be in a
beautiful part of the Suffolk
Countryside a special landscape area
just happened to be unfortunately
adjacent to a substation and therefore
it's really convenient and really easy
to generate electricity there
um so I too
um I'm torn uh quite I I really don't
know which way to go on this application
we so rarely hear anything about grade
two arable land here in mid-suffolk I
would be interested to know I'm not sure
if it was in the papers
how much
um grade two land we actually have in
mid-suffolk I don't think we've got a
lot
um other applications that we've had
before us at committee we have talked
about grade 3A and 3B but we see very
rarely do we get anything that is above
grade three so the very fact that part
of this site and a reasonable proportion
of this site is on grade two listed
grade two arable farming land uh is my
biggest issue with it really the fact
that it is our we don't have any grade
one
um land so grade two is our best land
and here we are proposing that we put um
solar panels on it and yes I agree
um with much of what was said by others
about the fact that we need more and
more electricity
um the uh unfortunately Society seems
more bent on
trying to get as much electricity as
possible rather than reducing how much
we actually use but that is just Society
for us and and I don't think we can do
an awful lot about that
um so yeah we need electricity
um and and it seems to be that we are
being uh Hostage to the fact that this
is next to a uh their substation
I'm also very concerned about the
cumulative impact when you see that map
that we were shown on the presentation
of the other two large applications that
that sort of um tracks of beautiful
landscape will be if all of those
applications are approved we'll just
become a sea of
um solar panels in a beautiful area
adjacent to the substation
um okay we're only here determining that
we've got before us but the very fact
that it has a reasonable proportion of
grade two land is making me lean
slightly towards refusal but um I'll
listen to see what any if anyone else
has anything more to contribute to
convince me otherwise
um but I I think this is a really tricky
decision for us to make thank you thank
you okay okay I'll give my view then
we'll go around again um that's okay so
um yeah I agree with everyone this is
this isn't easy
um we absolutely want to encourage
Farmers to diversify we've always said
that it's important that businesses
evolve and move forward but we've heard
very eloquently spoken from the parish
councils and from the Ward member around
the concerns and the impact this is
going to have
where I sit
um
cl11 is a significant consideration the
best most valuable land I think is
something that to me hasn't been I
haven't there hasn't been pushed out of
my concern pile by the officer's
presentation today I think we've had an
excellent presentation but that still
concerns me significantly if I look at
page 32 we've got paragraph 174 of the
mppf mentioned in paragraph 7.3 we've
got policy fc1 we've got policy CS5 and
policy CO2 and when I look at all those
and the impacts of those on this
application they actually still ring
alarm buzz me I again look at those and
think actually quite of those are
relevant and cause me a concern
and again I can't just put those to bed
and think um you know those are actually
overridden by the benefits that this
scheme will bring so I I won't be
supporting it
because I'm not comfortable with what I
see before me but also it's been made
clear by the case officer that an appeal
is likely anyway and actually uh you
know I think I feel for Mid Suffolk this
isn't right but I think it'll be down
probably for the inspector to determine
if the whole thing is right for Suffolk
and I feel that's that to me I'm
comfortable with that route so that's
the direction I'll be taking
cancer possible here next thank you
um thank you Matthew right I've made my
mind up so I'm going to formally propose
rejection for the following reasons and
by the way we do need to listen to local
people it's not an awful lot of point in
people putting submissions in and there
is such a weight of public opinion
um against this proposal
and I do understand the the plus points
uh as well but I think on balance
um I'm formally going to propose
rejection on the basis of
um I do think it compromises and takes
out of
um
very good agricultural land out of
production and I think that to me is
important I am concerned about the
impact in a special landscape area I
think that's very very important indeed
because we don't have big areas and I
mentioned earlier when I spoke regarding
tourism biodiversity and these sorts of
things I do think that is is
particularly important so for those two
reasons
um that's why I'm going to move
rejection if anyone wants to support it
and I do agree chairman
if there is an appeal pending then that
does not mean the applicant will not um
be successful overall so there we are
you have it that's my view and I'm
therefore proposing rejection on for
those two reasons primarily
and and I know Council ham just wants to
I think come in a second yeah
do you want to add anything to the
points raised no I think I think they're
clear and cl11 is the Killer and again
it'll take you back to page 31s right on
the top of it which which moved my
direction in that way uh and again the
public opinion on this
um we are here to think about the
benefit you know benefit specific
benefit benefits for the nation we need
to listen to our residents as well and
the people on the ground who we
represent so and for that reason I will
secondly um
I just think of a couple of other things
on my playlist just cumulative impact
yeah which I think you know we've talked
about we've heard about it
um that would be something that I'd
Chuck in there and I I would go back to
paragraph 7.3 7.4 7.5 and 7.6 because to
me they are part of the material
consideration they offer me I don't know
if they are for you
Council Matson yeah
thank you chair yeah yeah just just to
to briefly understand my point about
producing electricity near at hand to
where it's consumed transmission losses
are very significant we learned that
some years ago when we had big
um proposals around that so that was
that was useful the it's interesting
that that um what councilor Hicks has
just just been pointing to is is very
much the other
um part of the things I wanted to pick
up which was which was about the
conclusion the paragraph
um 15 the balance and what what worries
me about that is that the balance is
being struck almost entirely
without reference to our policies now
the the we're told that development plan
is is all these very stiff and things uh
insofar as they're consistent with the
mppf and so on and so on but I think
that the that they are absent from that
balance and I think they should not be
absent and
um
so that then comes back to what others
have said and and I think it was
particularly unkind in that balance to
suggesting 15.3
um
there are not otherwise considered to be
any uh adverse impacts on Heritage
ecology
etc etc will at the immunity crucially
now I think that is that is very
wrong really one has to say wrong in
terms of
the rest of what we've got in the report
and what we've seen on the screen and
what we've heard from the
parishes and their objections
um but there are adverse impacts and our
job usually and in this case is to
balance those adverse impacts with the
benefits so
that's the difficult balance to strike I
hear what others have said about that
and I think on the whole I'll
I will agree with refusal in the hopes
that we'll see better applications come
forward which are not on the the best
land and
um
that are in other ways less less
impactful but but suggest this does not
have impacts on all those uh
categories he's he's not not right so
I'm sorry about that but I'll have to
vote against it with a heavy heart
I'm going to ask which to speak
okay so Philip will need you just to put
together what we've said so that we have
something written that can then be put
on the voting
Jim can I can I suggest um it might be
appropriate for uh you to allow me five
minutes with proposer and seconder and
then we can put heads together and give
you something that can be voted upon
please
so if the page in a second is just
confirm with
okay welcome back everyone so um we've
had a proposal for refusal from
councilor Passmore on a second it for a
second uh proposal for refusal it's been
seconded by councilor Humphries uh so
before we get and no one else wish to
speak so we are going to go to the vote
on that but we're just going to run
through the reasons for refusal that
we'll be voting on
thank you chairman so the first reason
relates to best and most versatile
agricultural land and the reason is as
follows the presence of the development
on best and most versatile agricultural
land would unacceptably reduce the
availability of this land for the
optimum purposes of agriculture
the benefits of the development are not
considered outweigh this impact and the
development plan expects that particular
protection will be given to such best
and most versatile agricultural land on
this basis The Proposal will be contrary
to policy CS cl11 of the adopted
Midsouth at local plan and contrary to
the nppf paragraphs 158 B and 174 B
uh the second reason chairman uh that
councilors uh have coalesced around is
the industrial and utilitarian
appearance of development would result
in a significant change in the character
of the site and be visually intrusive in
appearance for the duration of
development
this change would have an unacceptable
adverse impact on visual character
communities including for public rights
way way users the community and for the
benefit of tourists the development will
neither protect nor enhance this valued
landscape forming part of the designated
special landscape area here on this
basis The Proposal would fail to
safeguard the landscape quality of this
part of the district county to policy
cl2 of the adopted mid-suffolk local
plan and compromising the landscape
character and local distinct of the site
distinctiveness of the site contrary to
policy CS5 of the adopted course
strategy
proposal will be contrary to the
principles of the nppf including
paragraph 174 A and B and paragraph one
five eight and the development would for
these reasons not represent sustainable
development under paragraph 11 of the
nppf thanks Jim
so on that basis can we please go to
version hand over to you
chair
yes just confirm a vote four is for
refusal
share members that's six votes for
refusal and one against therefore that
is refused thank you
thank you very much okay so could those
that are leaving leave now because we've
got to go straight into another
application so if I could ask you just
to leave a script as you can so that we
can move on to the next item of this
I could ask could I ask that you do
leave the chamber as quick as you can
please just so we can get on to the next
item thank you
all right
okay so we'll now move on to the next
item on the agenda
uh oh we're just waiting counselor
sorry we're just waiting for councilor
burn to come up and
sorry I have to wait a minute
let's start without the board member
okay so we're going to move straight on
to the next application which is
dc2204021 which is a planning
application in the ward of powergrave
melas road yaxley now hand over to the
case officer so Bron welcome back and
we'll hand over to you to take us
through this application
thank you
yes so this application is for a
synchronous condenser so I'll just start
with explaining what that is so
synchronous condensers are complex of
equipment that are necessary to provide
um grid stability infrastructure
basically so they are look like sort of
substation type equipment other sort of
electrical installations and they ensure
that the transition to renewable energy
Generation
Um is met with stability for the grid so
the transmission of electricity around
the grid and between the point of
generation to the grid is stabilized by
equipment such as synchronous condensers
particularly because features of
renewable energy generation are that
it's intermittent so it's not always
windy it's not always sunny and so you
get
spikes in electricity generation and
lulls equally so synchronous condenser
is not a generator it doesn't generate
any electricity but it stores and
um
and feeds that energy in to the Grid at
a continuous and even rate so it sort of
stabilizes that Supply so that's what a
synchronous condenser is so we'll go
through the slides and explain about the
site in this particular development so
next slide please
so the application site is on
agricultural land just to the north of
yaxley and you can see the a140 and I
Airfield just on the right hand side of
this slide you can also see a winding
access route that is a temporary access
for construction purposes it's currently
in place and it's being used to
construct the axley substation which is
adjacent to this site but the
operational access will be from Lee's
Lane which is to the South it's just
leading up to the site in the center of
the image there next slide please
this is just a wider view of the context
of the application site so you can see
Lee's Lane in the center of the slide
here leading northwards up to the
application site the main square of the
application site it then turns around
the northern side of the application
site and goes off to the Northwest where
there's a small cluster of Residential
Properties otherwise you can see the
immediate area around the application
site is undeveloped agricultural land
and it occupies a fairly elevated wide
open Plateau landscape in the
countryside you can also see a larger
portion of the eye Airfield complex and
you can see some of the properties
leading into yaxley along the bottom of
the slide
next slide please
so the constraints map just gives a bit
more policy context to what I've just
shown you you can see the rights of way
Network in the area so the footpath
network which goes around the IR field
you can also see that Lee's Lane turns
into a bridal way right of way as it
leaves the site on the Northern side and
there's also a bridal way along Judas
Lane
um to the to the west of the site
and you can see some of the listed
buildings in the area around yaxley
Village there's also listed buildings to
the north of the site which you'll be
able to see in in another slide a bit
later next slide please
this is a layout of the site showing the
layout of the equipment you can also see
part of the yaxley substation site on
the um on the left of this image so
that's not part of the development it's
development that's currently under
construction but you can see how this
compares to that site there and you can
particularly see how Lee's Lane passes
along the Eastern side of the site and
then turns around and crosses the
northern part as it heads up to those
properties next slide please
so just a slightly wider view showing
the context of the proposed development
with the site area for the substation
which is currently under construction
and you can see where that connects into
one of the pylons which is in the 400 kV
line between Norwich and bramford
next slide please
it's just a bit more detail of the
layout of the various equipment and that
the complex would be surrounded by 2.2.4
meter high Palisade vents so similar
sort of fencing as there is over on the
Airfield
next slide please
this slide in the next slide just saying
showing some elevations of the various
elements of the development
um and there is a building an acoustic
building to house the parts of the
development which are noise generating
um that is air insulated and it has a
maximum height of 12 meters which
Compares it's very similar to a building
I'm going to show you in a second which
is the building which is the axley
substation so it's similar in appearance
to that it looks like um a fairly modern
agricultural buildings or industrial
building
um so fairly fairly common sort of
structure less common is the rest of the
electrical equipment
and that you can see here uh the Yaki
substation building has a height of 10
meters so they're similar in in scale
next slide please
it's just more cross-section elevations
through the equipment so that you can
see the layout of that next slide please
this slide is just showing a bit more
detail of the proposed uh mitigation
planting so you can see where that is
around the site
next slide please
this slide gives a wider view of the
landscape so you can see a bit more
detail because some of the issues that
have come up in
um in objective exact objections excuse
me
um arise from from some of the points
that you can see on this slide so
goswald Hall is a listed building which
is just to the northeast of the
application site
and is is just marked on there you can
just see it frankly in Gray it's titled
goswell tool so where the bridal way
shown in brown here goes northward and
then starts to turn Northeast Cosmos
hold is just there you can also see
rights of way which go east to west
shown in green here
um footpath rights of way so there are
some images from from there and
um you can see
other things like uh Residential
Properties shown in in the most
immediate Residential Properties shown
in pink
and some of the other
um constraints so you can see he
actually religion you can start to see
um parts of thrandiston and you can see
the Airfield Etc
next slide please
this slide I've included because it
shows you the zone of theoretical
visibility that's come from the
landscape visual impact assessment
that's been submitted so this helps to
explain where within the landscape the
development would be visible with the
the greatest visibility shown obviously
closest to to the development in purple
and then the visibility of the
development decreasing as you get
further away or depending on the
intervening topography Etc shown in dark
blue mid blue and then light blue and
then and then areas of white and Beyond
the Beyond The Zone it wouldn't be
readily visible so you've got that
information and you can see some of the
viewpoints shown with
um pink triangles so I've got some wider
landscape views similar to the last
presentation just to show you the
landscape setting which I'll run through
in a moment so if you need to know where
those viewpoints are we've got those
here next slide please
so moving into the photos this is taken
from Lee's Lane
um close to the axis so where the car is
parked there that is the access suit on
the
um right hand side of the slide where
where that car on the opposite side of
where the car is that's the temporary
access coming across from the a140 comes
to the bottom of the application site
and you can just see some containers and
a portable toilet Etc that was used for
the construction compound for the yaxley
substation and the application site sits
just next to that so next slide please
so again looking at the application site
Beyond this Harris fencing
and you can see the National Grid pylon
in the background there as well
and you can see the relative sort of
flat Plateau landscape character you can
also just in the background on the right
hand side see towards the Residential
Properties at the end of Lee's Lane next
slide please
and this is looking from Lee's Lane
where it turns into a bridal way
directly across so westwards across the
application site so you can see it's
sort of scrubby Agricultural and this
was taken in summer when it was
obviously very dry but you can see you
can see the sort of landscape setting
there at close hand next slide please
this is an image of the temporary access
from the a140 so this as I say is
currently being used for the
construction of the yaksi substation and
is proposed to be used for the
construction of this development as well
but not for the operational phase so
we'll would then be
um stocked up and and reinstated next
slide please
so view towards the site from the a140
next slide please
so that's the axi substation development
as it was currently under construction
at the time of this photograph which was
a little while ago but you can see what
I mean about the
um the Fairly typical sort of looking
industrial agricultural building with
the gray with the gray paneling
next slide please
so that's a wider view looking across
um towards the axi substation you can
see the site would be adjacent to that
so you've got the setting of The
substation
um but also you can see the pylons but
you can also this gives you a sense of
how flat the landscape is in this area
next slide please
again a wider view just looking over
towards the development you can see more
of the pylons there and again just a
sense of that flat Plateau landscape
next slide please
so these are some of the views taken
from the landscape visual impact
assessments these are the wider
landscape views looking not of the site
itself but looking towards the landscape
towards the site so you can see how it
sits within the landscape so if you from
the 140 towards the site and from the
old Norwich road towards the site
next slide please
and from melis Road at the top and Judas
Lane right of way respectively on the
bottom looking over over towards the
site next slide please
um and from Green Lane
um and the right-of-way which is close
to goswald Hall
next slide please
uh and the right way on the Northern
side of Gosford Hall and from over I
Airfield next slide please
and your opposite it has some images
taken from goswald hall because there
were concerns about the impact on the
setting goswell toll and what the
intervisibility uh between goswald Hall
is the building and
um the site would be so this is taken
from a first floor window of goswald
Hall itself next slide please
towards the site I should say this is
from the garden towards the site
you can just see in the center
background you can just see a bit of
pylon
behind that tree line and the next slide
please
is from the field just to the south of
God also a little bit closer to the site
looking over towards the side
next slide please
I think that's it that is it thank you
so you can see in the report that I am
explaining water uh synchronous
condenser is and also
um
explaining that this type of development
is
identified as a critical part of the
transition to renewable energy
generation and Net Zero Etc to support
the ongoing transmission and stability
of the grid National Grid have a project
called Pathfinder in which they are
looking for developments like this to
help support ongoing transmission across
the network and this proposal if it were
to be built would be built as part of
the Pathfinder project
they've been a number of concerns have
come from local residents and
particularly actually in thranistan
Parish councils which I've addressed in
the report and you can see how I've
dealt with the various concerns
particularly there's been particular
issues regarding noise
um also the um
surface water drainage
electromagnetic fields and the impact
that that might have on health and
Immunity and also Visual and Landscape
impact of the development
and I've dealt with each of those in in
the usual way dealing with the topics
and going through the advice that we've
received from technical consulties
should also start by saying that this
land is is grade three agricultural land
and we don't have information submitted
to confirm whether or not it's three a
or 3B so whether or not it's best in
most versatile so you'll see in the
report that I have dealt with it on the
assumption that it is best and most
versatile but similarly to the
application that you heard previously
it's a relatively small area
um it is constrained to a degree by the
um the way that Lee's Lane travels
around it and sort of encloses it and
obviously the axley substation compound
to the West as well so we're concluding
that there would not be
um a reason on the basis of loss of best
and most versatile to weren't refusal of
the application but we are assuming it
is best and most versatile in the
absence of any information to
demonstrate otherwise
the highways impacts as I said using the
temporary axis from the 14c and then
after that using for operational period
just using Lee's Lane and the the
traffic for operational period is
expected to be
personal car or small van
um perhaps occasional visits once a
month or so just to um to inspect and
maintain but otherwise the the um
development is generally operated and
maintained remotely so it's on manned
um you can see some concerns that I've
covered about the landscape and visual
impact and as well as the Heritage
impact but hopefully you'll appreciate
from the images that I've shown or the
character of the landscape is that the
proposal includes mitigation mitigation
in terms of planting and that it sits in
context with the yaxley substation and
close proximity to that so overall The
Wider views are going to be seeing those
two things together which has has um has
the effect of ameliorating the overall
impact
in terms of noise
um and other public health and safety
impacts so
um concerns have been raised about noise
and particularly whether there's been
enough information provided we've had a
noise assessment submitted which
includes cumulative assessment to taking
the impacts of the substation as well
um we have the the information submitted
explains that the development would be
in in acoustic building to mitigate the
noise impact from the development and
that the conclusion is that there was no
a
I observed adverse effect so that's
basically the lowest
um impact outcome that come from a noise
assessment your environmental health
officers have had a look at the proposal
um and are satisfied that the
information that is submitted is
sufficient in order to make a decision
and we have a recommendation from them
to
um if we're going to Grant permission to
include a condition to ensure that they
want the installation is
um is operated that it's tested and to
demonstrate that then that the predicted
noise levels are achieved and that if
those levels are not achieved that
attenuation measures are agreed to
ensure that the predicted sound levels
are are not exceeded
that's in your recommendation
um EMF simile
um I've covered that I've got a section
in there just to explain that
um the EMF produced by the development
is uh generally considered to be
negligible is the same sort of thing as
a as any other kind of
um electrical equipment like substations
Etc or a large generator and that there
are separate um regulations that
um that govern the installation of
electrical equipment that
would not need to be duplicated by
planning and give you the the comfort
that the installation would be
carried out as it should be
um so I'm just looking to see what else
I've got in terms of the oh that's right
so the other thing that one of the other
things that the parish council had
concerns about was the surface water
flood risk and we had quite extensive
um
interaction between
um the applicant and the lead local
flood Authority Suffolk County Council
on the basis of surface water and the
applicant has provided detailed
um information on infiltration rates and
um
uh
and that has now satisfied the technical
advisor in terms of the information to
be provided
um and that subject to a condition to
secure an appropriate strategy for the
for dealing with surface waters that
there would not be a reason to refuse
the development
so
that's
sort of an overview of the main issues
and impacts you can see the rest in the
report obviously so I'll leave it there
for the moment thank you
thank you very much very much
so any questions to the case of so
councilman yeah I just I think my
questions are going to be for the um the
applicant um I just want to make sure
the applicant is with us good thank you
uh Council of Phil
thank you just perhaps to dispel a bit
of my ignorance um not quite clear why
um uh something to add inertia to the
grid and provide reactive current
compensation was necessary at this
particular location so could you tell me
what actually connects at the yaxley
substation I'm not aware of what that is
yes so the the location for
synchronous condenser type development
so good stability development is it
needs to be within proximity of a grid
Supply point so the axi substation is
that grid Supply Point
um the the further from that point the
less likely the less effective it would
be certainly but also the less likely it
would be to be awarded
um a contract from the grid under
Pathfinder so that's why it's located
here
um connection for yaksi substation It's
associated with the Progress power
development
part of that um
that development
does that answer well which Progress
power gas fired power station
it is and that would have lots of
rotation and inertia in any case so just
uh before that perhaps I should stop
here I won't be able to cover that
because the applicant if you've got
technical we'll do yes okay um thank you
and your
consideration on noise you wish your
awareness operational noise assessment
means an assessment and action to ensure
the noise reaches sensible levels
because very competent noise report you
had did seem to suggest noise close to
the building was pretty high
yeah so we're recommending that once
everything's installed
um it's tested for operation to
um to check that it complies with the
with the assessment with the outcome of
the assessment and in the in the event
that it doesn't that relevant
attenuation is is a scheme for
attenuation is submitted and approved to
ensure that it doesn't exceed those
predicted levels
um thank you chair thanks Bron for your
presentation
um yeah I was just going to check that
the reason for it being here is because
it has to be next to the substation so
that's answered but the noise issue um
do you have any detail on what the noise
is in relation to the substation noise
as to whether it's similar more or less
or or whatever and can you just
I wrote down the heights but I just
wanted to double check you're saying the
substation is about 10 meters high
and the highest point of this would be
about 12 so just two meters difference
is that correct
yes so the substation is 10.5 to its
highest point and the the highest point
of this building would be 12. okay so
10.5 and 12 right so that just just the
question about the noise versus the sub
noise from the substation and also in
the conditions it's got about
landscaping and I just noticed that it's
a very it's quite open some of the area
but
um could you just give a bit more
um
few on what type of landscaping would
entail thanks very much
I'm going to come back to you on the
noise because I just need to open the
noise assessment it did include a
cumulative assessment but if you want
some figures I need to just open that up
and come back to you if it's okay please
or just something that gives us a
understanding so whether it's a if it's
if it's a bit louder or quite a similar
kind of thing
sure okay I'll find that in a moment
um on Landscaping let me get a bit more
detail on that as well hang on a second
okay so the scheme that we have proposed
if I could ask Alicia please go to slide
so you'll see in the recommendation that
um notwithstanding the detail that we
have here we are asking for more
specific detail to be agreed so that we
know exactly what we're getting because
I know that members also have concerns
about specific species and things like
that so we'll get that that extent of
detail by condition but you can see here
the areas of Woodland so proposed native
Woodland planting
in these sort of bubbled areas
and some Hedgerow as well
so a mixture of those across along all
boundaries except for there's a tiny bit
on this side obviously but with the
substation there's less so on that side
to be conditioned the conditioned the
details to be conditioned
and on the noise do you want to come
back to us on that bronze yeah
uh okay councilman
next uh thank you I'd just like to to
um clarify my understanding of the
planning history
um and then I might there's a sort of
follow-up question
um I understand that the actual
substation was part of the Progress
power
station whatever it is which doesn't
appear to be a sort of normal planning
process
and if I'm right in that it seems to
have sort of your report it didn't have
a number or anything
um so is there something that has
changed in
um progress Powers
operation that now requires this or
should this or was this anticipated when
the whole Progress power thing got
permission
foreign
okay thank you yes so Progress power
um and the substation is part of that
um are an nsip so an actually
significant infrastructure project so it
is um the planning process is slightly
different because it's determined by
um the planning inspector and
mid-suffolk District Council were a
Consulting rather than a determining
Authority as part of that but it's dealt
with so it's dealt with under planning
legislation the planning act rather than
how the country planning act just a
different bit but it's a similar sort of
thing so they have a development consent
order which is similar to a planning
permission they have on that consent
they have a series of requirements which
are similar to conditions one of those
requirements was the details of the
substation and so that that was all sort
of comprised in in that
um
it's the same process in terms of
participation it's just a different
person making the decision so Community
participation Etc there's the same
opportunities to engage with the
decision-making process
the this proposal is not actually
associated with Progress power this is
not um necessary for Progress power
they're not interlinked in that way this
is to provide grid stability and and the
opportunity has arisen because there is
a new grid Supply point
as a result of yaksi substation so their
stability will be provided across the
whole of the transmission Network in the
area and this is just the point at which
that that is happening on that Network
all of the all of the connectivity that
increases the risk of instability is
predominantly all of the offshore wind
that we have in the area so things like
sharing a Michelle galloper dungeon and
all of those
um which we obviously have the
commitment to increase all the offshore
wind generation but that intermittent
generation and supply to the grid has
the knock-on effect of of risking
stability so we're seeing an increase in
proposals for instability and structure
like this and they need to go where
there's a grid Supply point and there's
not many grid Supply points across the
transmission Network
we've just been speaking about another
one at bramford
um and there's a handful of others
across our district but um that's the
reason for it going here
very much Council Passmore who are next
yeah just a quick one
um has any of the work already started
because I drive past the um exercise
just to clarify none of the workers
started the access road running like
that at all the access road is in
because it's being used for the
construction of yaxley substation yaxi
substation is nearly complete so the
building that I showed you in the photo
that's the yaxi substation but for this
development nothing of this development
has started and the temporary access we
actually sub will be used by this
development as well
but
um apart from that nothing
counselor Byrne you have a question
chairman I just wonder whether
my experience as the ward member and the
fact that I was heavily involved with um
the Progress power application whether I
could add a little bit to the
um resonator or the rationale behind the
substation
um I think when when it was moated I
think you can hold that for your ward
members you can hold that back for your
ward member statement
uh right well I won't bother including
it in that case it was just I think
that'd be the time to put it in sorry I
think that's the time because it's
talking about the bigger pictures okay
the ward
thank you
um any other
points of clarity before we move on no
okay so we'll move on to the parish
council we have uh Mr Freeman welcome uh
you have three minutes uh whenever
you're ready
I hope I've pressed the right button
there
um not just correct Miss Curtis on one
point please before we go any further
the access to the substation is with an
agreement with the yaksi parish council
there is no agreement with Conrad power
and
Conrad energy
at this stage for them to use that
access
so that is incorrect statement just to
put that correct can I just also ask if
I've got six minutes because I'm
representing two Parish councils okay
Jackson Parish Council objects to this
application being heard at this time as
it has not received a response to its
freedom of information request
the last meeting of the parish council
was attended by representatives of
comrade energy who were unable to give
the information that the parish council
required
the parish council sent a series of
points for clarification which you
should have seen which when returned
were unsatisfactory
Parish Council had no choice but to make
a freedom of information request in the
hope of obtaining answers to his
questions
the parish council has promised a
response to this request Freedom of
Information requests yesterday which did
not materialize
um I at that stage was considering an
injunction against this meeting
continuing we took legal advice and that
hasn't gone ahead
the parish council has never been
provided with all the information it
required and now it's been let down by
mid-suffolk District Council the only
way to resolve this is to adjourn this
meeting
and hopefully mid-suffolk will provide
the documents which the parish council
has asked for
and it will allow the parish council to
make informed decisions and to decide on
whether it wishes to continue to object
to this application
the parish council has given Conrad
energy every
or two
explain its situation we've had three
Parish Council meetings to which they
were invited and also an on-site meeting
at the last meeting we were frequently
told they couldn't tell us the answers
to the quest actions which we had been
asking for some time
there are other points which I'll make
but I see I'm running short of time
one thing I would draw your attention to
is this dismissal of the flooding issue
which if you look at the photographs you
won't have seen the videos is a very
extreme problem in the area caused not
by just this but also by The increased
amount of hard standing impervious
surfaces on I Airfield and landowners
and farmers and people associated with
River waveny are very concerned about it
thank you
um so we've received you did write to us
asking us to suspend the meeting uh I
have raised that with officers the
viewers that we've done everything
correctly in the meeting can proceed is
that correct
correct yes German I I was made aware of
the correspondence yesterday and
about repeat the advice I gave to the
officers
um who who spoke to me
summoned and papers have been sent out
in these matters Parish councils are
always those are duties and notify the
parish council or the planning
application that's been that has been
done
um it's not the fact that there might be
a free I can't I have no knowledge of
the detail of time dates and time limits
on on the Freedom of Information request
the fact that there may be an
outstanding Freedom of Information
request is not a
a reason in itself automatically to
defer a meeting or or remove an item
from the agenda or and as you're aware
chairman when we publish an agenda that
is the agenda it's not an as you also
all members of the commission recall it
does happen very occasionally that we
there's something unforeseen happens and
we agree with you as chairman that we
the officers won't present a report then
we ring round email round and say
to the parish council applicants I'm
sorry no point you coming
um I think as you're also well aware
it's not unknown for this committee to
defer his decision on an item because it
you feel you have good enough
information there aren't answered
questions and that has cropped up from
time to time on highways heritage
on any issue but that's your decision as
the counselors who have the duty to make
the decision that's all I can say really
okay so on that basis we will be
continuing um any yes any questions yeah
on on that that is that useful useful
points here what can I ask
um the parish council representative
um what sort of information
that is being sought but has not been
provided I mean it may be relevant to
their
um their view about the thing but is it
relevant to us
um is it the information that we ought
to have as the committee
what is the document you're waiting to
see well
clearly a document is waiting for
information that we've asked for on what
I was just going to explain that if it's
giving
and we're waiting to hit to know why
this um cannot be built on our Airfield
because the concern is that now with the
substation there and now another
um I'm going to stop you but I mean I'm
sorry I'm stopping you thank you very
much that we are only looking at the
applications that before us the
application could be anywhere else
that's not relevant we can only use a
committee look what is before us and it
is on this site before us so I'm not
going to ask you to continue thank you
I believe that covers it we are only
allowed to look at what is before us not
alternative places for it that's a
that's the rule of planning on the front
I'm sorry I was going to get to that but
you've backed me off before that point
thank you very much if you turn your
microphone on
uh Council field
uh you mentioned uh that you looking for
noise data I was just going to say I'm
sure I saw quite comprehensive noise
report in the uh online uh is is that
not adequate for you
do you just want to come in on those
because actually bronze just going to
come in on that point
yeah thank you thank you chair
um so there is
a noise assessment that's been submitted
uh which includes a cumulating
cumulative noise assessment
um cloud3 Ben asked about a comparison
for noise level so I've just picked that
out of that assessment
um so
um the substation is in the region of 80
decibels
and this is very rough obviously because
it as you know noise depends on various
different factors this is just a very
sort of ballpark so Ace decibels for the
substation typically and uh the hot the
highest
um sound for the
um various equipment in synchronous
condenser development 92. but the thing
to bear in mind is that um what we're
asking for and what they they've said
that they can demonstrate is that the
level of operational noise would not
exceed the existing background noise
level so that is the existing noise
level that's experienced at the various
sensitive receptors those Residential
Properties that were that were measured
and the condition is asking to ensure
that them to ensure that they
demonstrate that operationally the
development doesn't exceed that and if
it's shown to exceed that that they then
um Carry Out attenuation measures that
they agree with us with our
environmental health Team to ensure that
level is kept to no greater than
existing background
thank you Council Mansell you had a
question uh yeah thank you um you
mentioned
um uh concerns about floods
and I'm just looking at section 11 of
our report
um which which the our Consulting about
floods has said that they're they don't
consider any unacceptable flood risk so
um could you
um explain why you're not happy with the
um why you disagree with the um our
floods consultant
you should have seen photographs of the
flooding in adjacent fields which has
worsened in recent years and it is a
result of what is happening on I
Airfield but also there are now going to
be two impervious areas on this local
land which is causing a likely to cause
an increase in flooding on that land I
hope you've seen those photographs
because I have sent them in and it was
also a video attached showing the impact
the only referral back was that it was
stated that this has been a wet Autumn
which is incorrect I have
weather data on the area which I can
refer to which shows that that is an
incorrect statement in fact if you think
back to last summer how dry the period
was
and therefore the rain this Autumn and
again into the winter and remember that
the Autumn is September to November in
meteorological terms and winter is
December to February and in the winter
period again the rainfall now thinking
we've had not had any rain for well over
20 days
is very low again
flooding has occurred
thank you any other questions to the
parish council
thank you very much next we'll move on
to the ward member because we have no
objection no support sorry I'm wrong we
we have no address in this but now we go
to the applicant and again you have
three minutes please
good afternoon my name is Jonathan
Cooper and I work for comrade energy who
are an owner and operator of energy
Assets in the UK
proposal in front of you today is a
direct response to the climate and
energy crisis being faced within the UK
in the past 12 months unprecedented
Energy prices caused by geopolitical
events have threatened the security of
our energy Supply and resulted in an
increase in UK household fuel poverty
just last week the UK government set up
the department for energy security and
Net Zero to provide dedicated leadership
on the UK's energy Supply
National Grid as the UK electricity
system operator is adapting our grid
Network for the transition of our
sources of power away from traditional
fossil fuel generation including coal
and gas to renewable forms of power
primarily wind and solar generation
as a result of this transition changes
are required to maintain a stable
functional grid network with Solutions
such as synchronous condensers
the Pathfinder 3 initiative from
National Grid seeks to meet these
changes by procuring grid stability
services from carbon-free sources by
third-party contracts to address changes
in the current and frequency of the grid
Pathfinder 3 contracts are estimated to
save UK energy consumers an estimated 15
billion pounds by 2035 and avoid
significant carbon emissions in their
Pathfinder procurement National Grid
identified five regions of need
including the east of England where
within the next decade nearly 10
gigawatts of offshore wind generation is
proposed
these contracts have now been awarded
including to the pros site before you
National Grid based their decision on a
combination of costs to the consumer and
effectiveness of solutions to meet their
requirement for grid stability
the area chosen for this technology was
selected due to the connection Point
into the new yaxley substation
identified by National Grid and the
final site location is based off the
proximity to the substation which is
directly related to the effectiveness to
respond to faults as well as
considerations on topography ground
conditions access routes and Commercial
availability
The Chosen site benefits from existing
and proposed screening and the
development has been designed with an
aesthetic comparable to the yaxley
substation and to a modern agricultural
Barn not dissimilar to those found in
the region
technical reports have demonstrated a
negligible impact on noise flooding
visual impact ecology transport and
safety we have no objections to the
scheme from any technical quantity on
this ground and are compliant with local
National planning policy we've listened
closely to the concerns raised with
regards the application and have sought
to address these where possible we
intend to continue working with the
community throughout the Project Life
Cycle
in conclusion this project is set to
play an important role in fulfilling
National Grid's requirement for a stable
and functioning UK electricity Network
as the country continues on a path of
delivering Net Zero noting the
recommendation for approval in your
officers report we hope that members
recognize the clear need and benefits of
the scheme to improve the application
thank you
thank you very much
um questions I guess a question that
comes out of what the parish council
asked is did you consider alternative
sites or does this have to be located
right next to the
existing site
so the identification of yaxley
substation has come straight from
National Grid in the Pathfinder process
I mentioned about the five regions of
need where each of these regions there's
a requirement for the stability Services
based on the Renewables available
um an identified substation has a place
where we can connect into and then if
you were to connect into a substation
which didn't have an available Bay to
connect into it's a significant increase
in terms of the time to get a connection
onto that the cost which is ultimately
passed back to the British public and
disruption so that's the uh was the
reasoning around the substation itself
yeah we heard that um
the new facility will be on the contract
to National degree does the contract
come before or after the facility is
built
the contracts will come into effect
after the National Grid substation has
been erected
and in operation not not what I'm saying
I mean the synchronized whatever it is
condenser will that be built before you
um get the contract or would it be built
after you're awarded the contract the
contract has now been awarded to comrade
energy and to a handful of other
services across the region there's
certainty of use okay thank you
thank you yeah the
um what I'm I mean this this relative
locations and so on I mean in terms of
electricity transmission losses which is
presumably what the national good are
concerned about I mean the the Eye
Airfield site is what 300 meters or 500
meters or something away which
electricity transmission terms is
insignificant in itself
but you know is it nevertheless
significantly
worse to put it on the Airfield site
than it is to put it where it's proposed
the proximity substation is the number
one consideration in terms of the
effectiveness of the technology and then
that has been determined by National
Grid themselves will have applied an
algorithm on the effectiveness of
solutions presented to them and the cost
which is passed on to the British
consumers
I think we've got to be careful because
we can only look at what is before us we
can't go off on it could be better
somewhere else that's not what we can do
as a committee so please kind of just
remind members of that yeah I know we've
gone down a bit but I do need to remind
us yeah councilor e Bern and councilor
field
um thank you chair this is a question
for the officer um Ron just on the
flooding issue the suds I noticed on the
landscape
um
diagram there's the subs Basin
um and just to confirm that that does
meet the or which level of flooding
requirements that meet is probably my
question thanks
yeah so the usual expectation is that
the calculation is on the basis of a 1
in 100 event for rainfall
um but you'll see from the advice from
County that uh we're still asking for
specific details of drain instruction to
be agreed by condition so whilst we have
some information which is demonstrating
that it's um uh practical we want to
just be precise about exactly what we're
securing
castlefield
a question about the noise perhaps first
the report I believe says that the the
impact on the nearest receptors are some
way away is as you say negligible DB or
so but the noise level we are quoting or
one was quoting adjacent to the building
seems to be around the level at which
hearing damage occurs
um so just you know
how does your reasoning go on that
this is a rural area so it doesn't
matter what the noise level is except at
the houses or whatever
it's a noise assessment we have
submitted has taken into effects the
cumulative impacts with our site and the
axley substation it's captured the
output of our plan all the operational
equipments and against the background
levels and we are performing with
British standard National policy as
confirmed by the environmental health
officer
the background levels where
so the background levels would have been
measured from the nearest residential
receptors
which are how far from this equipment
I believe it's approximately two to
three hundred meters away I may be wrong
thank you
and the reason for happening I've got a
map John do you want to have a look at
it we've got a map environmental I did
look yesterday
um
uh the second thing is the reason for
connection here is the grid connection
that's presumably not just that the
wires are available at ground level does
it include the Transformers and things
that the need for those that exist
within the the actually
substation or does this synchronous
motor actually work well I'm sure it
doesn't work on 400 KV but
can I just clarify on your question yes
I'm just saying we're trying to
understand why it has to be here
clearly there's the issue of wires which
connect from the 400 KV overhead lines
to ground level where your motor sits
but I was wondering if you that motor
works at relatively low voltage you know
33 KV or something and therefore
requires other equipment which is
to translate its voltage to to the
higher level of the grid it
we do have Transformers as part of the
scheme but the connection Point into the
substation we can only connect into a
grid Supply point for this type of
Technology of which national Grider have
only identified three within the region
which are which have these Bays
available to connect into of which all
three have projects now contracted for
and the plans show a current Transformer
that's what you're talking about our
current Transformers I'm not familiar
with being used in that sort of location
yes that's that's the purpose of the
Transformer to step up to the voltage no
that's not a current Transformer then
again
thank you any other questions no okay so
we'll move on uh so next up is the ward
member councilor burn over to you
thank you chair
um just to clear up the um we actually
substation size
um it is larger than it needs to be to
connect the uh Gaslight Power Station
the Progress power gas five power
station uh this is because
um at the time it was a question it was
National Grid's decision to make it
larger in anticipation of the
requirement for further connections
simple as that
and cost efficiency says the bigger uh
the bigger the better so um it was
larger than was required for Progress
power
um
right thank you I'll I'll do my best
to get through this this has been a
complex and Technical application for
interested and affected parties to
assess it's not surprising that those
with no prior knowledge of electrical
engineering have found it difficult
this unfamiliarity imbues within us a
sense of reverence for the subject and
it is unsurprising that we think that
those who are more informed must know
what they're talking about even if we
don't
the problem is that this reverence puts
us at a disadvantage when it comes to
challenging an application like this and
it must be difficult for those on the
other side to resist taking advantage of
our relative Ignorance by being
selective and slow with what they choose
to disclose you've heard that this has
left you actually Parish Council in
particular lacking Vital Information
before being allowed at three minutes a
day to persuade you of its case
however fortunately a resident in the
area has stepped forward to offer advice
which has considerably helped some of us
to counter the disadvantage
quite fortuitously his professional
qualifications and working experience
with synchronous condensers make him in
my eyes an expert witness in the present
context he wrote and I quote I have
constructed several synchronous
condensers and energy centers as part of
my role as senior project manager
infrastructure lead in Wembley London
and he's provided invaluable information
to individuals in the area since his
original representation to miss Suffolk
much of what this gentleman has said
informed Mrs Fleming's lobbying email
which was sent to you yesterday and I
will be drawing on some of it here
it is a landscape impact that is felt to
be the most damaging pointing out the
fact that the substation was originally
to be situated within an ancient field
pattern that was accepted as being of
regional if not National significance
was sufficient to persuade National Grid
to change the substation configuration
from their preferred air insulated
open-air version with all its tall
gantries insulators and switch gear
covering a large area to a smaller gas
insulated type contained within a
building covering a much smaller area
there is mention of this Iron Age field
pattern in section 6 of the officer's
report on landscape
and visual impacts in fact 6.4 says your
officers conclude that the area is not a
valued landscape
in the nppf sense so it is qualified
I think there are I think there are
three main questions to be answered here
is this an appropriate site
a quick key question is what informed
Conrad Energy's choice of sight for this
development
a question that the applicant seems
never to have fully answered on this
point our local experts if I may call
him that tells us that
National Grid
will advise on the position to connect
into the grid
however I cannot see and this is the
expert my expert talking I cannot see
that the planners have been informed how
this question was asked by by the
applicant if you ask National Grid if
you can connect into yaxley as as it is
and is it appropriate then their answer
will be yes and this is because the
condenser can be put almost anywhere on
the network
the second second question
of my
three
is is this the best location
um I I realize that this is the
condition the location we've been
offered
um but
although the decision has to be taken on
the basis of this of this location uh it
could be a refusal on the basis of this
location I just give you that as a
possibility
so on the on is this the best location
on this point our expert says this is
determined by the efficiency of the kit
being in that location if it were looked
at purely based on the benefit to the
grid
as I that's himself speaking construct
these the benefit to the grid is not
always the number one priority cost is a
factor the location proposed is
undoubtedly the most cost effective way
of installing this it is a Greenfield
site with negligible contamination is
your construction
Etc it's a very good site from a cost
perspective
as I have not seen Conrad's calcs and
technical details I have no way of
determining that this site is the best
location for the condenser on the
network
it is unlikely that this is the case
based on experience and Conrad should be
required to provide their evidence based
on their studies for alternative
sightings of the condenser showing that
Alternatives have been looked at and is
discounted including why
and the third is within section 9 of the
officer's report which is on residential
amenity uh
Paris 9.4 to 9.6 considered noise
the applicant's assessment concludes
that together with the substation there
will be no observed adverse effect
however the advice I have received from
my
expert as I call him condensers can be
noisy based on the working load setting
and setting you should note that he
actually is very quiet at night time
with very little noise pollution
introducing this so close to residential
dwellings could significantly affect the
nighttime noise pollution for the area
the planners should dig deep into these
proposals and ask for evidence regarding
when Baseline noises were taken and
assurances by way of conditions on the
ground should planning be granted that
noise does not exceed existing levels
and this if I make make this point this
differs this isn't me speaking now this
differs from the suggested condition in
the report that noise Accords with the
predictions in the assessment
and back to my uh expert
in actually if Conrad has the freedom to
run this at full speed whenever required
a dull drone will be heard through the
night reducing living standards to
proximity dwellings noise travels far
and wide and I would not expect expect
this consent to be granted if I was
making the application
there was a fourth question is this
appropriate Hardware
an alternative is a capacitor Bank this
performs a similar role but is not as
cost effective to the applicant as
maintenance costs are higher the
benefits could be a smaller footprint
and less noise
so my conclusion I'm at the conclusion
now thankfully as I see it there are
many questions that have been asked by
affected parties but remain either
unanswered or not answered
satisfactorily without these answered
recent cases cannot be made nor can a
determination be based on sufficient and
adequate information
deficient areas can be summarized as
follows one
that's right the studies on Alternate
Brownfield or industrial sites
have been reviewed and dismissed
including the reason two provide
calculations and Technical data for the
sighting against alternatives to show
that this is the optimal location
three provide existing DB stroke noise
monitoring and readings of the proposed
area both day and night over a period of
14 days to determine existing ambient
noise levels and four demonstrate the
best and worst changes in ambient noise
both day and night for the proposed
completed Construction
and in my opinion and that's me
only when this information is available
to officers supporters and objectives
alike will it be safe to make a fully
reasoned decision on this application
therefore
I feel that the only safe decision for
you to make today is deferral or refusal
thank you
so that was 10 minutes
um
members any questions or comments for
councilor Byrne
no okay thank you very much
um right members we've had all the
information put before us over to us to
discuss debate and come to a conclusion
yes cancer Mathison and cancer field
yeah I
um
as I was as I was reading the report I I
gradually became
uncomfortable how heavily the the
arguments of principle and so on were
resting upon
renewable energy etc etc I became
increasingly dubious about that but I
think having heard the arguments and the
presentation
um I'm more comfortable about that
but I I am not I think that councilor
burners has alluded to some of the
history and I seem to recall that there
was when the power station was being
proposed and so on that was quite the
um argument about
we've allocated this huge piece of land
I Airfield for Industrial and Commercial
purposes why isn't it going there and
um I think I'm I'm left with the residue
of that
um
I've put aside the suspicion that this
is being put here to serve the gas power
station okay accepting that's not the
case the problem is the the
um only three points a good Supply
points that National Grid have put
forward in the region I'm not quite sure
how big the region is but I think it
tends to suggest it's several counties
at least
um so I I'm now really
still an easy as to whether it is just a
cost consideration it's a bit cheaper to
put it on this Greenfield site than it
is to to get an appropriate piece of
land on our Airfield to put that and the
the grid may want it to be next to the
substation but
how much of a problem is that actually
in terms of the connectivity and the
transmission I I can't feel as if I got
the answer to that at the moment really
Council field
and cancer Humphries
I want a similar views so I I
was concerned reading the paper that was
a lot about renewable energy and its
generation there on and yet this device
generates no energy at all it generates
reactive current to compensate for the
that which exists on the network but one
can accept that that with wind farms
switching on and offload quite rapidly
there may be quite substantial phase
transitions that you do need to
compensate
however in my electrical engineering as
you all know he's pretty pretty out of
date it comes from
50 years ago when the network wasn't
that different but there you go
um I can't help but feel that you know
the case has been made quite powerfully
that there's a range of information
that's been requested and it hasn't yet
been delivered
so I'm inclined to the feeling that yes
we should defer and until we have some
will
proof of the sort of information the
walk member and the parish council
requires none of it sounds that
unreasonable I think I've been analyzed
slightly the noise myself and that has
some good 3D modeling in it but it does
show that noise close to the plant is
high and that further away from the
plant is clearly a lot less it drops by
three DBS every time the distance
double so yes you'd expect it to be less
in the distance but
haven't really
investigated just how quiet you could
make or how noisy this will be adjacent
to the Machinery itself which is in the
countryside but nevertheless people walk
around there
the issue on EMF Fields I've certainly
got some papers on that somewhere so I'm
sure that could be obtained quite
readily the prime one is as being said
is you know just why does this have to
be just here not perhaps two or three
hundred yards away the the
electricity isn't going to change in
Phase very much over that sort of
distance so one would want someone who
knows what they're talking about to
produce that sort of data for us so
um you know I'm very tempted to to to
move a deferral but I think I would wait
to hear what other members feel before I
just going to have to remind you we can
only look at what's before us today not
where else it could be yes indeed but
it's the the question is why is it here
not why is it that's why it's here and
the applicant's chosen to apply here and
that's really where we go and if I argue
too much it'll finish up at Branford
Mr Sherman thank you um so I've learned
a lot today I didn't know what a
synchronous condenser was that's like
very interesting and it does say here
that really it's um it's for storage
consistency of electrical supply during
prayers of no low generation which we're
going to get with additionally renewable
energy so everyone thinks it's magic
it's not it has its flaws and one of
them is that it doesn't always work
doesn't always give you what you want so
this system is definitely needed because
it provides that stability and the
electricity Supply and those periods of
low and productivity so there's a reason
for it so that's the first point the
second point is it is where it is
because as the Chairman's just said
that's where the application is and it's
there for a lot of reasons one it's
close to the subsystem uh to the um
substation and that's where they've been
granted and they've spoke to National
Grid that's where they conclude that
it's going to be and it's before us so
we could all argue that it can be
somewhere else but it is where it is
um so I think there's a need it is where
it is the noise side of it there's been
a study done on noise and one of the
conditions of the recommendation is that
they're doing operational noise
assessment as well so that's captured
within the conditions
to me because there's a need and because
we seem to be driving towards this Net
Zero and the renewable energy thing for
me that gets my support it is what it is
I can't find any reason to say no
proposing or just listening
you know what I should I should go where
my mouth speaks and I so will propose
approval as set down in the conditions
because I think it is what it is
thank you Council Passmore you're next
um yeah I've listened to all the
discussions I am actually rather
concerned I do actually know goswald
Hall quite well because I used to have
some friends that lived there I have to
say that the size of this building going
up is pretty big and I am concerned
um
with the impact it has on the visual
amenity of the area I do agree with the
award member David Burns so I am not
comfortable I know it's got to go
somewhere I guess I know that and we've
got to look at the application as it is
um but I just think the impact there is
is is potentially quite damaging for for
local people and I would like to know a
bit more about the details before I
would be able to support it so at the
moment
um I'm not able to support it
and when I switched to speak yes cancer
mayor
yeah um visual impact is a concern
um
there's no mention of use of graduated
shading on the 12 meter sides
I think that would be a positive
especially if we manage not to have a
large red site slapped on the side of it
um
for me it comes down to noise
and I'm not sure the conditioning is
strong enough
can we
provide the ambient noise measurement
and use that as a Baseline and Link
further operation to not exceeding those
levels
so this enforcement haven't got any
wriggle room it's that is the ambient
level now and you're exceeding it
operation has to stop can we be as
Draconian or not as firm as that
okay can I just check I do need a second
though do I have a second at all
I would second if we can tie down the
noise condition okay fine we'll pick
that up okay
do you want to come in on the noise well
I was just because I think we've still
got uh Susan Leonard here from
environmental health who might give us
some more advice on the noise condition
hello hello there so I'm so sorry my
voice is is um a little bit iffy today
so I hope I can make make sense
um in answer to the question on the
proposed noise condition as Bron has
indicated what we are asking of the
applicant is something that we're doing
on more and more applications which is
to verify or validate that the noise
level
um but basically what they're proposing
isn't going to adversely impact the the
nearest noise sensitive dwellings the
residential locality
um and what we're asking for in this
instance is that the level doesn't
exceed as you say the background noise
level
um yes it would be possible to to
specify that within the wording of a
condition but essentially we would want
the applicant to demonstrate that the
noise mitigation attenuation proposed
affords that level of protection by
carrying out an assessment once the
um the equipment is all in situ and any
enclosures or mitigation is put into
place
so so the basically that will follow up
but you can assure the committee that
that work will take place once the
project moves forward if it's given
permission
the mitigation you will you will be
monitoring and in and making sure it
meets the requirements of which you lay
out in terms of background noise
we would we would ask that the applicant
provides an assessment post installation
um prior to coming into beneficial use
that
when operational it doesn't exceed the
current background noise levels that
would be something that would be
expected Council mayor's just got a
question
seems strange that we're asking the
applicant to provide the assessed noise
levels
um shouldn't they be assessed by a third
party
so if the applicant says no level noise
levels are okay it's okay
uh we would we would obviously need to
see the results of the assessment and
make a judgment on on the basis of what
we see but essentially if an applicant
says that
um you know that they would have an
independent
um
uh company acoustic consultant who would
under undertake that work on their
behalf if the report comes back and says
that levels of cord without that they
don't exceed the background and we
accept that if there were exceedances in
the future then that would come down to
a breach of a planning condition
okay
um yeah if you if you a couple more
questions yeah yeah just um I mean are
we
are we comfortable is the office are
comfortable that
um that further mitigation is is
technically achievable in these
circumstances if it turns out that the
noise levels are are as as councilor
Mayors um worry
yeah in terms of mitigation obviously
what what's been
um proposed thus for the applicant has
indicated that it will achieve will
achieve that but what we what we're
seeking to do is obviously if for any
reason it doesn't then we would want to
see a further scheme of mitigation so
there would be further mitigation that
would be
um you know achievable
thank you for that uh councilman you had
a question no I was going to add going
to voice my opinion I was part of the
debate am I allowed to do that if anyone
does anyone have any further questions
on noise why we've got the offset thank
you for your I hope your voice is all
right uh but thank you for that
appreciate it um right councilman
Council Eben uh thank you
um I I am I must admit I um I think I've
learned a bit more about what this
supplication is about when I came before
I came to the meeting I thought that
this this synchronous condenser was
somehow associated with the
um the uh Transformer connection to the
grid uh and I've now discovered that it
isn't really and it could go anywhere uh
and I've listened to what other people
have had to say about
um this particular location
um notwithstanding anything else that
might have been discussed about other
places it could go
is that wherever it goes is going to not
be a pleasant situation because the very
nature of the development is is not
going to be next to
um where anyone lives
it's likely to be in a bit of open
Countryside
um near a national grid line
um okay it it could be in a sort of
industrial complex where it would be
better cited
um but I think wherever it goes it it's
not going to be ideal it's just one of
these things that modern society has has
made a necessity however I do think that
there are some questions that haven't
been answered
um and maybe we could do with a little
bit more information about some of those
aspects as has been highlighted by the
parish and award member and um councilor
Fields also uh thought he needed more
information and and I am about his
Superior knowledge on electricity
generation and distribution
um so I think I'm
I'm not too sure about it but I think
um on balance I think maybe some more
clarity over the information would help
so unusually I think I'm heading towards
um towards a deferral type thing
just raised his hand and wants to come
back in so thank you for that
yeah thank you so reflection uh have a
listen to other people
um it's obvious the way it's going we
haven't got a second there so we have
Council mayor so did you actually so did
you get satisfied your answer yeah all
right cancel my last time
we'll all go to the boat but councilor
burn wanted to speak then we'll go to
the vote then we'll see where that goes
um thank you very much chair um I'm
slightly of the opposite view of of my
colleague on my right because I think we
run the risk of trying to understand how
um you know I remember my physics
lessons from schools but we run the risk
of trying to become
um electrical engineering experts and
that's not that's not what we should be
doing here today we should be looking at
the planning application in front of us
and the um that views that we've the had
from the experts that we as a district
council are obliged to to get
um and then we make a balanced View and
I'm of the view that if that more
information will be more information in
my personal views we have enough
information here today to make a
decision and um and I think also it's
it's
holding on us to make a decision and
it's not good for not just the applicant
but also for people the the local people
to put off and put off and put off you
know we heard earlier they were saying
two and a half years you know let's just
kind of you know I think you know we
should we should be making decisions but
that's just that's my personal view
um the the things that I've got a
concern about are
I'm not so concerned about the heights
now because
um
farming sheds these days are massive and
they are just put in the middle of
nowhere there's one near me that's on a
nice rise and they're just able to put
up a 12 meter 15 meter hard shed boom
nothing you know it's just no problem
despite the fact that's replacing a
1950s big star you know it's kind of um
so we've got 12 meter high shed next to
a 10 and a half meter high shed and but
my more concern with that is ensuring
we've got the landscaping around it and
that the Landscaping is significant and
not just the odd hedge that in a 15
years time might be my height kind of
thing
um I too like counselor Passmore I
remember standing in the driveway of
God's world 4 looking at the site for
wind turbines on our Airfield and and
thus debating whether
um what was going to be the impact of
those and now there's wind turbines you
know all over the place and we um
you know the general public it's a
different it's a different View and
Views are views change as well as the
view that you see as it were
um I do have a concern about about the
the noise
um and I would
want to ensure that that
um the condition with regards to noise
is
um
is really tight and that the um there is
somebody that has looked at those that
noise assessment and when I say somebody
I mean a noise expert that is
um on behalf of the council to ensure
that I don't understand the relevance of
noises I would rely on an expert so I
want to know that that the noise
um assessment is and it's not just kind
of you know loud bang noises or anything
it's um it's it's sort of General
background hum and impact on amenity so
I would
um I'd want the wording of that
condition to be
um really strong
um were it that the committee is
approves this application so my
main concerns noise and also the
landscaping and I would like to see you
know again if the committee were to
approve that there was really strong
Landscaping
to to
um I would like to hide it hide some 12
meter shares but it's coming on that
point okay so I want to go to the vote
but I think the Landscaping noise has
come up a few times and in the in the
you know we have limited words here so
can you give us absolute reassurance
that you've heard what we've said and if
it is approved that the noise and the
Landscaping are sort of you know on
turbocharged in terms of getting Council
attention
yeah um absolutely so taking the noise
first uh Braun has just been sending me
some of the wording so that we're
looking at
um requirement of the noise assessment
by competent individual so we would look
at their qualifications if it's you know
just written on a Word document we're
going to query that so we're going to
look for their qualifications we'll do
that with environmental health that it's
got uh background so excuse me sound
levels
one hour on La 90 during the day in 15
minutes La 90 during the night so
they're quite tight specific noise
levels that have come in through that
request and that we would do that with
environmental health so yes I think it
might need some tweaking from what I've
heard but I think we've got the
beginnings of a condition to work to
that and similarly with the Landscaping
we would expect that before commencement
and we would expect that implementation
you know the first Landscaping season
following commencements as soon as
you've got them okay well that's that's
as much commitment as we're going to get
today so I think on that basis we'll go
to vote see where that takes us
see what the next steps may or may not
be
Jess I'm just confirming that's been
proposed by councilor Humphries and
seconded by councilor mayor correct yeah
I think
I think so that vote is now in progress
thank you members that is four votes for
and four votes against so we are it is
four thank you chairs Crossing vote
means that hasn't now been carried thank
you
okay everyone so we closed the meeting
at 1 12. thank you very much